the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
titles and trophies are on the line at
the u.s juniors and senior championships
in st louis with the rest day and a
chance to recoup on the horizon players
left it all on the boards christopher ew
maintains his lead in the juniors with
his third straight victory the standings
are knotted up in the seniors with larry
christensen holding on to a narrow lead
despite stellar play in the girls
juniors sophie moore suzuki has been
uncatchable and unstoppable winning her
fifth game in a row for a full point
lead front runners have formed will they
pull away round six of sensational chess
coming up next
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day six of the
us juniors and seniors chess
championships held at the st louis chess
club we started a in the gorgeous forest
park as we are waiting for the players
to arrive after the rest day the players
are re-energized and recalibrated ready
for another day of battles over the
chesapeake let's go to the studio and
start today's ash
hello everyone and welcome to the
beautiful city of saint louis host to
three national championships the girls
championships the juniors and the
seniors brought to you live from the st
louis chess club at scholastic center
i'm yasser sarwan along with dorset hi
yes sir how's it going wonderful it's
great to see you back thank you very
much lovely to call the action with you
and christian today yes three national
championships wow wonderful right hello
everyone and thank you for joining us
yes the first five rounds feature some
amazing
fighting
chats this is great to see and we have
three
clear
leaders in each of our championships
dorsa do the honors who is leading the
girls the standings
well
five out of five amazing performance
sophie morris suzuki is just
having a having a tournament perfect
perfect jennifer you and talia cervantes
tied for second but a whole point behind
remarkable and in the girls uh pardon me
and then the juniors
we do have a girl playing in the juniors
yes we do
yep yes uh well christopher ew is having
another wonderful tournament four and a
half out of five uh followed by mishra
three and a half and andrew hong with
three points
yes indeed and in the seniors
in our seniors is still a lot of stuff
are going on
but larry christensen is
unclear first with three and a half
points
um followed by well we have three people
tied for or fighting for a second uh
uh maxine
thank you
not a problem and our format for these
three national championship stores kind
of a classic format uh it's a 90 minute
for the first 40 move then people get 30
extra minutes which is really nice
and uh then there's also the the classic
30 second per per um first move and you
know just increment yep no draw first
before the 30th move and the traditional
scoring system the one point for a win
half a point for draw no points for our
loss and we've had five rounds of play
but now we have four more are remaining
scheduled or so well it was a very nice
rest day for you yes
sure
and then we have around six seven eight
and nine boom boom boom happening back
to back and from today until well
saturday potential playoff for round
nine but the way this tournament is
going on i don't really know
exactly
and we're very fortunate to have
christian in studio christian good to
see you my friend you're going to drill
down on our tournament leaders
good to see you guys and welcome to the
show dorsa so far the tournament has
been filled with thrills and spills and
these are the best juniors and legends
of american chess that we are calling
the action from at the st louis studio
so far a lot of exciting games but let's
take a look at where the leaders are
standing in all three sections and we're
going to start with the us junior girls
section we have a dominant player in
that one sophie maurice suzuki the only
perfect player remaining in all three
competitions well what else can you say
about that scoreline just five victories
in a row dominant performance today she
will be playing rue yang yan tomorrow in
round number seven that is the big clash
against the rating favorite jennifer eu
a big opportunity in round number eight
against the struggling anne marie vela
and in round number nine well that one
is a big clash as well definitely an
interesting road ahead for sophie mori
suzuki and there you have it there she
is getting ready for her sixth potential
victory wow if she do we have a fisher
price in this tournament because i know
we do have the us championships
unfortunately not for this event but boy
that would have been nice five out of
five so far i have to say this young
lady is just simply impressing in this
event the best tournament of her life
and let's take a look at where our
leader is in the junior section we have
christopher you well he started off with
a winning round number one after that a
team a draw with the black pieces but
boom boom boom in round three four and
five a hat-trick of victories and right
now he is one point ahead of his nearest
rival and let's take a look at his road
ahead well a difficult road ahead in the
junior section today justin wang will
have the white pieces against
christopher you after that he will be
played facing in round number seven
broski round eight i this one is a big
big clash against the surging abi manu
mishra the youngest grand master in
history and round number nine a
potential opportunity for him with the
white piece against carissa yep who is
unfortunately struggling in this event
only one point out of five and
also we have the legends so let's take a
look at where our leaders stand in that
one and this is our leader this is larry
christensen well he picked it off where
he left it last year he was the finalist
in the tie breaks last year against
kaidanov and right now he is the leader
after the half a point three and a half
out of five up to this point and let's
take a look at his road ahead in the
last four rounds today a big clash
against vladimir akopian the rating
favorite going into this event the
newcomer only 50 years of age and this
one is going to be a big clash round
seven against navikov eighth against
chabalov and round number nine against
mr grevich and as you can see all these
players are having quite good
tournaments this is definitely not an
easy road ahead and there she is that is
carissa yip with her good friend
rochelle wu who is ready to face also
another good friend jennifer you guys we
have so many amazing games today we sure
do and dorset do the honors lay the
table for our viewers and tell us about
the pairings for the girls let's go for
it yes sir well uh we do have a few
interesting matches coming up absolutely
um
well first of all let's take a quick
look at sophie morris suzuki's game
because i have to say i'm really hoping
for six points for her
who's not hoping for six points such a
nice blast and she's paired against um
yen right which is um i mean she's
having a decent tournament two and a
half out of five but nothing compared to
sophie
jennifer you is hoping not to see sophie
score six points she's at four she's
playing rochelle
uh who we just saw on the screen and
honestly alice lee pardon me against
talia savantas those are our big
matchups and in the juniors what are our
big matchups for the juniors well uh i
believe christopher you is our uh
tournament leader here
yes beautiful and then we had um
mishra playing versus
yeah that's going to be another key
match-up absolutely absolutely and in
our legends the seniors
who is larry christiansen playing well
one and only vladimir kopian in our
absolute legends and now vladimir is
entering the tournament as the highest
rating yeah so for larry christensen
this will be a stern test max delugey on
board five against joel benjamin also
very good and nick defermin up against
dimitri we called him
dima girvich and here's our legends um i
was looking at larry's score um
scoreboard and it was like
you know it's technically it's time for
a win oh he's got one
and all right
lots of fights lots of fights and what
are they fighting for dorset well in our
girls section they're forging for their
fighting for a whopping 20 000 and 600
first place does get a
6 000 payday nice and and there is also
um
yes
well let's let's take a quick look at
our arduino sure well forty thousand
dollars yeah forty four
uh with the first place having twelve
thousand dollars and
eight
five
and it's really nice because you know
the tournament that you play and even if
you're still having a terrible
tournament you still go home with a
thousand dollars exactly so
and of course they also get a
scholarship right boats both girls and
uh our juniors do get a very nice ten
thousand dollar scholarship to the
institution of their choosing and this
is a very generous donation that is
funded by the dwayne barber foundation
and the usgs
and i just gotta say it's the wayne and
susan barbara foundation because uh
susan's wonderful
wife of the weight she was very very
supportive and in the seniors uh how
much are they fighting for i think
there's a scholarship yeah and no
scholarships for this but there the
first place does go home with a twenty
thousand dollar payday very nice total
price fund is 75 000 woof
the 13 000 second 10 000 third and round
six has started let's begin with the
game between rue yang yan
and she's up against a miss perfect uh
sophie
uh more suzuki and we have a
nice open sicilian yup and still uh
things are to be determined after c2c
for morocco i have to say yes sir i do
play this as white and i really did like
it it can get a little um
edgy but it does feel like a
nice choice for white now
what do you think should be the
tournament strategy for sophie she has
five out of five do you think she has to
do you think like what's her mentality
is she gonna like push push to win get
this whole perfect score well normally
speaking six out of six you're thinking
yeah like let's go for it but on the
other hand she actually has two chasers
yes who are only one point behind her
and it's more like well let's secure
victory first this was always my
thinking let's secure victory first and
then we can talk about legendary
you know
things and so i would say if i'm in uh
sophie's short shoes i'm simply trying
to
get a solid opening position and the
meroxie bind although i must say it's
with the move a2 a3 included
i'm not
i'm not a big fan of this move a3
well i mean i think with pawn on e6
because g6 didn't happen maybe that's
why
um she doesn't feel the need to play the
b3 early ons
but well there's no attack yet against
the pawn so the move bishop to
from fa to e7 by the way this again very
solid move uh no no problems there
uh i always liked these systems where
you played at early d6 and knight
to d7 to e5 i was always very
provocative in my approach with black
but nothing
bishop e7 is perfectly fine black is
preparing to castle and i think white
will sort shortly castle as well uh
we'll keep an eye on that one
i wanted to go to jennifer uh versus
rochelle for a quick second
okay this is a very sharp um english
system with g3 yeah
we we saw a number of games from the
candidates tournament which was uh
featuring uh ding lehren and nepo from
the very first round one and that was
with like knight uh c2 knight e3 e2 e3
preparing
knight c3 by jennifer and she doesn't
want to see the queen
going to the h5 square so we might see
for example knight f6 knight c3
queen e5 there's also so many moves the
flexibility of both players plans are
really broad at this point f2 f4 d2 d3
bishop g2 b2 b3 lots of lots of plans
for both sides we'll keep an eye on that
and just to uh build up on that one
yasser because there were some very
important stem games that i want to
bring to your attribution uh one of them
is a and with we have some windows
pop-ups forget about that
but that was a nice commercial inviting
windows commercials
on this specific uh tablet monitor
however you want to call it now the big
stem game is the one between shanklin
and karjakin and actually karjakin after
this game which shanklin won with the
white pieces was in a must-win situation
at the world cup and we know how that
ended he actually won
that game and eliminated shanklin later
on in a tie breaks but still from a
theoretical point of view this
particular line was revived by sam
shanklin with the white pieces he put a
lot of pressure in this line bishop to
g2 bishop to c5 a lot of pressure on the
knight on d4 i want uh to kick it
backwards right gain some more space
with the black pieces and also
potentially open up the d file for my
upcoming rook white says no no no i'm
going to keep this knight in the center
play the move d3 let's see whether this
is going to come on the board and by the
way these are not the only moves
nevertheless it does seem like this is
the main line and what we could
potentially see on the board queen to d3
castle castle rook to d8 it seems like
black is developing nicely with an
attack on the knight on d4 but now white
can force uh almost force this queen
trade with the move knight to f3 now if
you go to queen to e7 unfortunately
after queen to c2 it does seem like
white has the more more harmonious piece
placement in the position a3 followed by
b4 could potentially come as well we see
a bishop landing on beat when creating a
lot of damage on the long diagonal uh in
the position as well especially with the
queens still on the board so
after knight to f3 rook takes d3 knight
takes c5 was played in that game rook to
d8 and b3 and despite the fact that this
position looks quite equal and it
doesn't seem like white has a lot of
pull it's not as easy to find placement
for your pieces as black knight way six
sure you can put the knight on a6 but
where is it going to go after that and
my
plan is quite easy as white i'm going to
go bishop to b2 rook to c1 rook to d1
and then i'm going to make use of my
pawn majority on the king side as well
as in the center and if i manage to get
the king to e2 and then start pushing my
uh e pawn down the board well your
pieces especially the knight on f6 might
find it uncomfortable to uh find a good
position so definitely an intriguing
situation right now and we do have an
early d3 so not bishop to g2 allowing
the move bishop to c5 but immediately
hooking this pawn as you were mentioning
yasser white has so many ways f4 f3 d3
bishop to g2 with the move d3 this one i
have a feeling is going to be a very
complex battle and i have to say you are
talking about strategy what is sophie
mori suzuki's strategy well
jennifer you strategy is to win she
doesn't have any alternatives at this
point because she is trailing by one
point so she really wants this victory
and tomorrow let's not forget she plays
against sophie mori suzuki but she plays
with the black pieces a big opportunity
for her to strike with the white pieces
in this game and we know that she will
take the necessary chances to do so
absolutely thank you christian i'd like
to turn our attention to the juniors for
a moment and we have justin wang he's up
against uh the leader christopher yu
knight f3 very nice start d5 and where
is alejandro when you need them c2 c4
d4 and we have a
bank a reverse benco gambit something
that he specializes in with black you're
getting it as white and after uh
c5 and d2 d3 i once played against
victor korchnoy i was black and i have
played in this position
f6 he played against me a3
e5
g3 and i took the pawn
i just asked victor okay i am uh
i'm um
upon up you prove your compensation
benco gambit players will love white's
position
i took the pawn hung on and had a very
nice victory is black so we'll see if
christopher bites the bullet and
captures the pawn in that one and i was
just going to say that i wonder liang
and christopher was on the white side of
uh this position just a couple of days
earlier right against balagi yeah last
round instead of d3 he played the move
e3 the blumenfeld gambit exactly that
turned into blumenfeld that was what an
encounter that was i saw what surprised
surprises me uh though yasser and dorsa
is that justin is actually spending some
time right now
why is he doing that isn't he prepared
for this
if he isn't then he might get himself in
trouble because we know
these positions are very double-edged
and easily black could take over the
initiative well we do have d2d3 by
justin so it's now christopher who's
thinking should i be capturing this pawn
right away should i be playing f6 knight
f6
uh one of the things that's really
interesting about the bengal gambit is
often times both players are content
to leave the tension normally speaking
white does not like to capture on c5
because after it takes
these types of positions black gets to
develop bishop takes c5 funnily enough
white would rather not have his a2 pawn
like it just put it off the board uh or
something to that nature so interesting
that christopher is waiting i wanted to
say that a wonder liang who started so
badly he's playing the white side
of a karo khan a very tight black little
part of the black side of a very very
topical kara khan these days i remember
i was the
ladies
coach at the olympiad
in baku
and
katja
katja namsova had a wonderful victory as
white which robert hess had prepared
with her that very morning and i was
sitting there fretting the whole time
worried about katya's position and she
had it all worked out very very
awkward
situation for both players it looks very
strange
for black to be playing these uh h6 g5
uh advances
to the best of my understanding this is
all preparation from black side and
david is thinking pretty deeply about it
so actually pretty deeply about it
using the head
so um i mean i've played crazy the g5s
and h5s and f5s here and there which
were all prepped but it worked out so i
feel like as long as
wonder has his prep
memorized yes
i think this will be a fun game for us
to see how it turns out absolutely and i
wanted to throw
this one this open sicilian over to
christian
yes uh because uh we saw it earlier in
the tournament this night off with
bishop e3 e5 and this early
h3g4 christian
was becoming
quite topical these days and tell us
what the theory about this double-edged
line reveals it is and they're also
extremely complicated because black has
so many setups that he can start with
bishop e7 bishop p6 is one of them
bishop p6 followed by knight to d7
leaving the bishop on f8 is another one
of them bishop e6 with the knight coming
to c6 is another one of them they're so
confusing when you look at these lines i
remember i tried to study uh to study
this idea when uh i believe it was a
book by an indian grandmaster that came
along a couple of years ago i'm trying
to remember what the name of
him was but he was recommending this and
also analyzing uh and giving some notes
from vishwanath
so definitely a very topical line this
h3 g4 is becoming as white now h6 it
does seem like right now we only have
three games in the database and it was
set to raman now i remembered because i
actually saw his name here
with the black pieces with the black
pieces which is quite intriguing because
that book is from uh was from white's
perspective this one is a game between
ganguly with the white pieces and set
raman with the move g5 only two games uh
at this point some cupped gupta versus
petkov as well so we see a lot of indian
players it seems like this is some sort
of
national tendency
that's uh going on right now in india
take on g5 we expect knight takes g5
makes a lot of sense taking advantage of
the fact that you already committed the
bishop from c8 to e6 and now i'm going
to immediately put as much pressure on
it as possible so knight takes g5 knight
to c6 seems to be the best move and the
only move that was played in uh this
position the engines are saying
somewhere around equal 0.3 nothing
significant knight takes e6 f takes e6
and now the question is how are you
going to target this pawn on e6 also how
are you going to stop me and you do have
to stop me from playing d5 because if
black manages to get d5 in
get the pawns rolling down the board and
that's going to make it very
uncomfortable for my pieces the bishop
e3 will have to move the knight from c3
will have to move you cannot allow that
to happen that's why bishop to c4 seems
to be the main line stopping the move
d5n at the same time attacking the pawn
on e6 queen to d7 and once again the
battle continues rage is on uh for this
important square d5 queen to d2 followed
by castle bring another attacker or
defender the way you want to look at it
on the square d5
very complex battle is going to be
ensuing in this one but i have to say
whoever is the player that is better
prepared and knows better the following
plans well it's going to have a much
easier time in this very complex
position
thank you for that uh christian i just
have a question about uh because like
these g4s are so up and coming in night
off in the past few years um what about
the rook g1 g4 idea if that wanted to
happen without h3 when you know how
would that be
any recommendations any thoughts
feelings uh
in which exact position well it doesn't
necessarily have to be knight f3 but it
could also be um like you could go like
a knight e2 if you wanted
so many different
yeah so because if you want to get g4
you either have to like get rock g1 g4
or h3 g4 so
i guess it's just a matter of style
honestly but it's sort of like okay
let's go back for example to uh
this position the
the starting position the night or and
you know for so many years bishop g5 was
like considered
the most important
move
and uh before that move became the most
important move f2f4 was also uh
considered
to be crucial with the idea of getting
an early e5
now much much later the english
players began the english attack with
bishop e3 and f3 but in this exact
position after a7 a6
h2 h3
uh he came back popular and then
alexander shabalov amongst other names
played rook g-1 and tried to get in what
you were saying that that's where they
got in the rook g1 g4 and i tell you uh
the the white players have been breaking
their heads on the night off and i think
i was just seeing the world champion
magnus carlson even like just saying i
give up i don't know what to do i'll
play a2 a3 anticipating b5 b4 but
the vagaries of fashion and opening
theory are such
that
you really have to be incredibly
sensitive
attuned and
in
i'm just amazed that the top grand
masters can keep up
with all of the developments because
it's just sort of like you could get
lost
in this
in an ocean
of variations we do by the way have
knight c6 and i liked
uh what
you're thinking was something like maybe
just takes takes and isn't it time you
know like to remind that we do have an
open uh g file but again these moves
d65 as christian was mentioning
uh you got to keep that square
fully controlled because
you know black might be able to use his
e6 pump
no
like well i used to play close sicilian
forever because i just love playing f4
knight c3 yeah four g3 yeah yep and then
you know i'm starting okay i'm growing
up i need to start playing a little bit
more nice chess so i started learning
knight f3 y lines that the actual
open sicilian and um the first thing i
was told is black wants d5 your job is
to block that and i was like okay so all
i'm
the main thing that i tried to
create my openings around was to stop
that d5 and that's just something that's
because of the pawn structure something
that's going to just keep happening and
happening and happening all throughout
the game right yeah and that
especially with the double pawn on e6
uh the fight over that d5 square is such
that you're
it it's it's
that's the theater but uh
uh the theater of the battle is who
controls that square d5 uh again um well
let's ju let's jump over to christian
for just a moment well guys uh it does
seem like we have an answer uh as to the
question who knows the theory better and
the nuances of the position better in
this game between very important game by
the way between jennifer you who is one
point behind sophie mori suzuki and
rochelle wu and it is jennifer who knows
the positions better because rochelle
play this move after the move d3 and by
the way i really like this move uh d3
because for example if you don't take on
d3 take on d3 queen d3 bishop to c5
bishop to g2 would transpose to the line
that we discussed that stem game between
shankland uh and karjakin from the world
cup but if you don't take on d3 and you
say okay but i can also play bishop c5
first right and we're going to get into
something very similar no because i
don't play the move bishop to g2 i have
this extra wrinkle in the position i can
take on e4 and i actually like this
position is much better for white
because right now it does seem like i'm
forcing you to take on c3 and solidify
cement my knight in the center like this
with this two pawn c3 and e3 i really
like white's prospects at this point not
only that but this bishop very nicely
opened up and the b file is nicely
opened up for my rook so it seems like
all my pieces will be finding their
ideal squares so
d3 bishop to e7 after quite a thing was
played in the position but this
unfortunately doesn't correspond to the
requirements of the position the
requirements of the position was to
attack this knight as fast as possible
with the move bishop c5 and then follow
it up with rook to d8 you can no longer
do that with the bishop only seven not
only that but the queen and the bishop
are sort of fighting competing for the
same squares especially
this square e7 you would love to have
the configuration bishop to c5 and the
queen on e7 the queen for example and
it's going to get attacked you know that
once these pawns get off the board i
will have the move f4 coming down the
pipe so the problem is that with the
bishop on e7 queen to c7 more or less
looks to be the right square for the
queen but imagine a rook coming on the c
file and then all sorts of uh jumping
knights knight b5 knight d5 taking
advantage of the fact that this pawn on
c6 is pinned so
the way i look at the position this move
bishop e7 despite the fact that the
computer is not giving a huge edge is an
inaccuracy and let me show you a couple
of moves later on bishop to g2 by the
way was played he takes d3 now you can
start with castle or you can just simply
pick up the pawn i think the cleaner
version is to just pick up the pawn on
d3 castle castle right and we got to
pretty much the same position that we
had in that stem game but with the ps47
not bishop on c5 now the problem is
you're going to have a very hard time
attacking this knight on d4 what you
don't want to see as black is this move
c6 to c5 i understand you're kicking my
knight away but you're leaving behind so
many weaknesses specifically this square
d5 is going to be a weak big weakness
but also check this out after you play
the move c5 this monster on g2 is going
to control the long diagonal and create
severe dangers on that diagonal for
black so
most likely you will have to get the
bishop to c5 at some point but that's
just a loss of temple right and we know
that that loss of tempo will matter in
the long term so i'm definitely seeing
jennifer you in pole position to take
the advantage out of the opening now
let's take a look and by the way this is
a huge game for both of these ladies you
see rochelle wu is not that far behind
she's on three points seoul fourth
position with a win over jennifer u she
would equalize her scores she will jump
to four out of six sophie mori suzuki is
still in a dominant lead one point ahead
of jenny for you but let's not forget
jennifer you and sophie mori suzuki are
meeting tomorrow in a huge clash now
let's take a look at what's happening in
another one of
the contenders in the junior girls
section and that is talia cervantes who
is also on four out of five also one
point behind the leader and
we talk a lot about strategy going into
this not yet championship rounds but
still we're past the midpoint so they're
each and every point becomes extremely
important now what's talia's strategy
one point behind the leader well with
the black pieces you have to go for a
victory especially against alice lee who
unfortunately for her has been
struggling in this event let's uh put it
mildly has been struggling because she
lost three games so b6 this is the
position she chose a grunfeld uh talia
that was but uh it does seem like it did
not surprise alice lee right now ellis
lee has one hour in 33 minutes and talia
despite the fact that she's a pawn up
she has only one hour and 13 minutes on
the clock and i have to say this is a
pretty well known position
and uh i'm a little bit concerned about
talia's knowledge of what she needs to
do right now b6
if i remember correctly it's not the
correct continuation right i'm more
familiar with like
queen d5 exactly yes queen to d5
followed by queen to a5 put some
pressure on the square c3 and then
cover the b file but not with the move
b6 but with the maneuver knight to d7
followed by knight to b6 the knight
would be perf not perfectly placed but
quite well placed on b6 defending the
weakness on a c4 as well as potentially
getting ready to jump to a4 and create
some dangers in white position
this move b6
doesn't meet the requirements of the
position once again doesn't mean the
requirements of uh the theory right now
either so it does seem like white after
this move b6 got an advantage and alice
lee
potentially knows it because she is very
well versed in theoretical knowledge and
she does seem to be surprised by this
move b6
thank you for that christian uh your
commentary of doesn't the
the move doesn't fit the requirements of
the position really makes me smile
because
when i was starting chess the soviet
players
they would annotate games and that was
like their
favorite phraseology this move doesn't
fit the requirements of the position i
would always think to myself
what does the position require you know
like
like let's throw that right back at them
turning our attention to the game
between larry christensen our tournament
leader in the legends versus vladimir
okopian uh we have a nimzo indian
um
rubenstein with e2e3 and
you know it's funny for me that so many
players like
putting their knight on e2 where i
really just
for me i find it to be the more passive
square than
knight f3 but 92 certainly is a mainline
variation d5 and we're going to get one
of those
classical isolated queen pawn positions
after the move castles yes
exactly but uh queen takes d5 now the
queen's going to go i don't know
often times it will go home to d8 or
even to a5 how about the other way to h5
yeah okay
um normally speaking
on the h5 square strangely enough it can
actually become
oftentimes a target especially
i like it when the knight is on f3 i
don't like it when the knight is on e2
so for example after queen h5 we'll
start with the move a3 okay and just
invite you to go backwards all right
let's say bishop d6 okay
yes exactly and this is kind of what i
mean by uh
being
a target in the sense that of knight
takes uh and
maybe you're you're happy to trade
queens and
maybe you think that this is not that
like it's even stephen but i have a
little bit more activity at the end of
the day you can always liquidate that
spawn in this scenario exactly another
if you don't like a2a3 is white you
could also play the move queen c2 which
oftentimes leads to ideas of either
knight g3 or knight
uh f4 but i'm sure queen h5 by the way
is perfectly playable perfect
and in fact
there you go uh your choice squeeze h5
uh very nicely let's play this as black
so i always like had like okay do i want
to go where do i want to go i want to go
h5 a5 well
let's go h5 so i can try to get
something happening on that d4 pawn but
it's not i mean it's not my dream
position to be honest right but yeah the
pieces like if i could have that bishop
from c8
honestly anywhere else
i would i would love this position but
it's like i need like five more tempos
to get my pieces off right so that's
just i don't know it feels a little
uncomfortable and so far i believe larry
has been blitzing out so he's been very
comfortable with the opening uh
yeah so small on my screen i think
uh the producers are doing their best to
to to accelerate my blindness you know
like they put
the names in like this incredibly small
script
that or leonard has you know an angst
against me leonardo just sets up my
computer and just nails me i want to
turn our attention to the game of
gregory kaidanov versus alexander
chavalla no d5 because again this is a
page right out of the very recently
played
um
candidates tournament c2c4 i think it
was richie rapport i'm going to have to
ask christian to help me out on the two
players with bishop f4
i believe it was actually duda who
played this against ritchie rapport
that's when the white pieces yes and he
actually got a he got a crushing
advantage good good position he ended up
having this break c5 that uh
i think it was a
d6 right or no was it knight to e7 first
because i know he was uh
he was not finding the right plans
that's for sure or at least he wasn't
aware of what exactly the right plan is
and at some point allowed this idea of
uh cc5 right exactly
and again that was uh duda versus
ritchie report we'll keep an eye on that
game because again
gregory kaidanov doing quite well i also
wanted to just check in on maxim
another one of those players who is tied
for second of the seniors
i am seeing a trend a lot of the a lot
of our tournaments uh top players
understanding they are having a nice
timing
because maxime has
full time an hour and a half um playing
quickly yep and when we're going a
little bit farther is joel benjamin who
starts to think a bit more a bit more
and a little bit further one more move
yeah and here joel benjamin has been
thinking for i want to say 15 minutes at
least right yeah so
very normal uh practical approach by
white here uh the problem with black
setup is actually this knight on c6 this
knight on c6 is misplaced you're right
and uh you really want to
[Music]
deal with that and it you you you could
return the two bishops and just you know
end up trying to fight and find a better
square for the night but what black
wants to do is kind of punish white for
giving up the two bishops so a move like
let's just say i'll put down bishop e6
for just a moment
and something where
i know i want to play bishop d6 right
but i don't want to encourage knight b5
oh yeah if i play bishop d6
and i get knight b5 then i'm afraid i
will just lose the two bishops and i'll
be slightly worse
with the
carlsbad pawn structure so i may end up
having to play a move like a7 a6 a move
that magnus carlsen for one will have no
trouble playing as black and then put
the bishop on d6 if i can do that with
black then i'm kind of a happy camper i
think i've
solved all my opening problems but uh
joel benjamin you were saying really
slow slow play at this moment yes after
bishop e2 if you make that yes
i'm seeing joel benjamin well nope he
did not no that that that's actually our
analysis um he does he he's uh down to
an hour and nine minutes so he's been
thinking for a good 15 minutes here and
yeah if that pawn was on c6 this would
be a dream position exactly easier to
play yeah all right well uh we'll keep
our eye on the legends what have you
been looking at christian i'm looking at
the junior section guys because uh in my
opinion this is another big big game of
the round there is andrew hung versus
carissa a because andrew we know with
the white pieces has been spectacular in
this event not only that he won his
first uh two games but uh he got
advantage crushing advantage out of the
opening in all of them so i was
definitely having my eyes on and see
what he's going to bring to the table
because karissa decided to go with the
king's indian defense once again a very
aggressive approach and she got
completely crushed by a wanderer liang
with this idea of bishop to e2 followed
by an early h4 she had no idea how to
respond to that one but
it does seem like for this one she came
prepared because
she blitzed out her moves up to this
point she was expecting h4 and i'm sure
she had something prepared for that but
andrew said no
i'm not going to go into that line i
know you've spent a lot of time and uh
pretty much solidified your repertoire
against the move h4 so i'm going to
surprise you first i'm going to go
bishop to e3 this is the move that he
played and after already an immediate
thing a six minute thing for karissa she
played the move c5 so she did not expect
the move bishop to e3 d5 e6
and now we see a transition from a
king's indian structure into a benoni
structure now
i myself i am a benoni player
nevertheless
i do believe it's quite a suspicious
line quite a suspicious opening and i do
not recommend it to any of my students
if they do want to play it i'm going to
be like okay you do your research you do
your
theoretical
research as well work as well but you
should expect that you're most likely
going to have worse position out of the
opening the question is how much worse
and let's take a look at what happened
bishop to e3 knight to f3 take on d5
take on d5 knight to g4 once again
after a seven minute thing and
i see this move and i know it's not the
right direction because i've never seen
this move knight to g4 in this
particular setup what black needs to
focus on is finish his development first
and then you can start focusing on all
of these gimmicks with knight to g4
followed by knight to e5 so first you
have to get the knight to d7 in order to
be ready to do that knight to g4 was
played bishop to f4 now if you go knight
to e5 i'm just simply going to take if i
manage to change the pawn structure from
this with the pawn on d6 to this with
the pawn on e5 and a nice defended
passer on d5 this strategically is just
a very bad version for black the best
black can hope for is to somehow fly a
knight to d6
set up this this blockade and then play
the move f5 you're very far from
achieving those goals and you have clear
problems that you need to solve first
this pawn on c5 is a big problem
by the way the engine is saying plus 2.5
at this point so it gives white a
decisive advantage crushing advantage so
after bishop 4 she played the move f5
but now i just simply take on f5 which
he did andrew did uh and i'm looking at
the position
and i'm seeing a very bad version of the
benoni not only that it's supported by
the engine's assessment as well it
already gives a plus 1.1 and not with a
move that i would be thinking about in
general when you take on f5 uh as white
you expect either g takes f5 or bishop
takes f5 right rook to f5 seems to be
the best move by far to support this
idea of knight to e5 but you know this
rook on f5 is going to be in the way and
at some point is going to get targeted
by my bishop coming to d3 i don't like
the prospects of black's position for
example if you go bishop to xf5 i'm
going to simply make a natural move what
is your knight doing on g4 you would
love to get it to e5 but knight d7 to
support it doesn't work you're losing
the pawn on d6 if you go rook queen to
f6 to defend the pawn on d6 and then
prepare to move knight to d7 well
unfortunately after h3 once again if the
knight goes there i take take and i
change the pawn structure once i change
the pawn structure and this one becomes
a
passer on a d5 i'm going to get it to d6
i'm going to have a crushing attacking
potential after the knight lands on d5 i
i really don't like what black is doing
what carissa is doing not only that but
it doesn't seem like she understands the
position and this is quite concerning
right now this doesn't really feel like
her style as well
and
in my experience with her but um
just talking about it feels like her
style yourself it doesn't no it doesn't
yes yes and i mean to be honest i mean
when you're kind of at the what do you
call it the seller
yes
i think the seller yeah she does she
does she has no chance of you know
winning the tournament so i feel like
she might just be like well i've been
thinking about this opening let's go
just you know your spirit is kind of
crushed a little you're just not really
having a good tournament so i
i don't know i just i feel bad for her
well it's a bad opening it's a full stop
i mean if you're going to play
i think it was david bronstein who first
said that if you play the king's indian
it's like you're giving your opponent
pawn
advantage
so i mean that's like pretty strong
right um okay but if you go for a a
transition into a suspicious benoni then
you give your opponent a pawn and a half
with a pawn and a half right okay so
she has recaptured with the bishop but
all the problems that you've been
pointing out
about this pawn on d6 about the fact
that the knight on g4
uh is not going to land comfortably on
the e on the e5 square indicates to me
that charis has just got
outplayed in the opening this is not a
good position for her
and after either h2h3 even castles you
got to be concerned about knight d6
pardon me uh knight b5 hitting d6 uh
correct me if i'm wrong but she's gonna
play in the olympia team right yes so
great so this could be a nice like hey
that's what we
we spoke about that it was a training
for her that she wanted
a stiff challenge to get her ready
for the olympia team i just like to
break away from these games for a moment
to go back to the game uh between rue
yang ian
and sophia um suzuki because i vote my
whole life
i i my whole career i want to say i have
played
as black um the hedgehog
which is what she has
on the board i've been doing this stuff
well just hedgehog the hedgehog so
you're a shuba enthusiast
well
his book came out much later
from
my
praxis uh
there are i had a coach in my early
teens
whom uh with i only trained the hedgehog
this is i was going to his place and for
three hours he was just showing me
hedgehog games one afternoon and i had
to play them and i have to say it was
quite depressing for a few years
because i was always on the defense
always waiting for white to find the
right way to strike and uh if white by
the way doesn't do anything
what does black do right if i manage to
contain your breaks with b5 and d5
then we're just going to be sitting
around and shuffling the pieces and
white can at any point just simply offer
a draw and you cannot do anything about
it right this is what concerns me about
the hedgehog what is your opinion of the
hedgehog well funny you should ask
in my view
there was a very very famous game it was
actually played on the radio
uh in sweden wow yeah between yeah
yeah between olfa anderson and bobby
fischer oh that's why you should
remember it bobby fischer was black
all right
and
and what uh what uh um
christians just said do you play for d5
do you play for b5 bobby fischer in such
a position played king h8 oh my yeah and
let's just put a boom on the board for
just a moment king h1 and he played
rupture
just shuffling a little
he's playing for g5 i like it the famous
attack g5 95 g4 and bobby went on to win
a very very famous game
another approach that black has in this
position is attached to what you just
described as the break d65 and the way
to do that is you play bishop back to d8
now again i'm just going to put a move
on the board just so i can exemplify
what i'm trying to suggest is the bishop
goes to c7 and it's funny you're cramped
but you now suddenly have this threat
let's make another poor move for white
for just a moment and this is the break
that you do you you want to take on h2
with check you're threatening to take
twice on e4 and things of this nature
and then finally the third approach you
can take is to play for this crazy b7 b5
oftentimes you throw this move in
you then play d5 you sacrifice a pawn
and
that's an approach
you do not play
you let me repeat myself you do not play
what sophie play
this is right
yes exactly rookie 8 knight b3 h5
uh
that seems to be her preparation right
because she's blitzing it right out like
that but
all my career like you would never run
your pawn
to h4 because it begs the question could
i play queen f2
in uh tickle the ponzo a little bit well
i i'm a pound grabber i want
to capture either the h4 pawn or the b6
pawn and ask you why did you encourage
this type of play now i understand that
if you defend the b6 pawn and if i take
you could capture this pawn
right because that is a
um you win your pawn back and it's a
tempo against my queen
but very very often this pawn on b6 well
you know
it could get tickled uh and i
think
well we have some moves what do we have
what happened fast after h4 bishop f4 95
oh she played bishop f1 h4
bishop f4
95 takes queen f2 similar idea
double attack
why i wanted to give up my dark square
bishop or not i'm not sure what what
were you about to say
after polish for the first thing i want
to do i just want i just want to play
punish three just stop that pawn
movement and just kind of be like all
right g3 is weak but what do you want to
do with this well that's the problem i
think that uh you're inviting
the the the approach of knight to h5
often times when you're cramped in these
meroxie bind
um
if you all you need is really one good
square for your pieces the knights black
knights
are often on the wrong squares and they
they they
they fight
uh for the same square the knight on g3
is actually a pretty good but yes please
say it even if you do it
even if knight h5 yes i'm trying to go
by your logic of let's eat pawns yes
bishop g5
bishop to g5 because the bishop
took the queen
h4
all right just a second let's see what
we've got here
bishop to g5 eat pawns
nice um
let's go knight g3
take take queen g5
queen takes d6 i was thinking at the end
of the day so yes you're right queen
takes d6
queen g5 takes h4
uh but at the end of the day what i was
thinking i was going to try to do was
take your pawn on c4 i see so that would
be
essentially lots and lots of trades
now at the end of the day you might be
happy you might be thinking as white
that you've got some advantages and
stuff like that
um
let's just catch up with the players and
see where they're at
uh because this was a very uh surprising
approach
by rue yang she played bishop f4 takes
place
bishop f4 takes takes queen f2 and
something similar i i wouldn't have been
that eager to give up my dark square
bishop uh
christian help us out here is this
line
been played before
i was looking uh
i was i was looking at the database and
they were indeed following uh a couple
of games with h5 bishop to f4 indeed was
the novel wow this move surprised us as
well because knight 25 bishop takes e5
it doesn't make a lot of sense to just
simply give up your dark square uh
bishop just like that so
bishop to after h3 knight to h5 bishop
to g5 exactly what you guys were looking
at this is indeed
one of the main
propositions in this particular line a
game between oleg sienko and mohammad
played in 2016. and this one was quite
an interesting game because i was
looking through the engine's
recommendations and they didn't seem
clear to me at all so for example bishop
takes g5 queen take g5 knight to g3 if
you take on h4 i just simply take on f1
pick up the pawn on c4 and it's quite um
easily um visible the fact that black
has no problems whatsoever so
you have to defend this pawn on c4
somehow and that is to just simply
sidestep this attack of my knight with
the move bishop to d3 and now the
complications are starting to pile up
after specifically this move b5 and i
have a feeling that sophie was very well
prepared now
the way i look at this position is maybe
from an objective point of view with the
best moves for the next five six seven
moves white is going to be able to have
a slight edge but
if you make a slight inaccuracy and
there's ways in which you can make a bad
move at every single corner because you
see this there's a lot of pressure on c4
if you take i have queen a7 coming this
is another consequence of this move b5
opening up this threatening diagonal
towards the king king to h2 and now
knight to e5
you feel it coming right now i have a
checkmating threat in two moves
takes f3 followed by queen to f2 so for
example if you just take on a6 yes good
luck let's sign the scoresheets and go
home take on f3 queen to f2 checkmate so
you have to be very careful and this is
what sophie maurice suzuki was banking
on with her preparation i really liked
what she did in this one bishop to f4
surprised her but knight to e5 makes a
lot of sense this is what we have bishop
to c6 is indeed on the board and by the
way the best move and it does seem that
after bishop to c6 first of all you
cannot take on h4 because knight takes
c4 is just going to give me a crushing
advantage um i regained my pawn but also
the pawn structure is much better i have
the two bishops they're opening up your
king is very unsafe with the two bishops
on the board it's not looking good you
cannot take on h4 and after bishop to c6
look at the clocks guys there's a 30
minute difference between white's clock
and sophie's clock one hour and 31
minutes she hasn't spent a single second
on her moves in fact she gained one
minute
confident play by our leader sophie
maurice suzuki and look at her posture
right now
i know what i'm doing you don't right
well bishop f4
giving up the dark square bishop
voluntarily that's um
well that's not
not not what uh what you do with white
individuals what i just wanted to
mention because
it's always funny to have an extra
language handy
uh so the um
the hedgehog in farsi is jujitsuri
again
jiu-jitauri
okay i just want to bring that up
because hedgehog sounds like jujitsu to
me
oh yes you do so much that's pretty cool
what about a romanian is there a
specific name for a hedgehog
again
so in chess like would you just say
hedgehog or reach
i say hedgehog
i don't think in romanian anymore i
actually think mostly in english
nowadays yeah it took me maybe five to
six years of living in the us to start
thinking in in the language exactly
see the problem is i'm late again it
does seem like we need dorsal we need
your predictions i will go with sophie
i'm gonna do christopher you can can i
change my
guys
can i change my prediction yeah right
moderators know nothing
for the girl for the for the ladies i i
i have to say talia she's just one of my
dear friends
we were on still chess team together i i
just
for me italia even though i i
shh
she's doing quite well in the event so
that's another one
and you're joining two others and it's
about friendship too yeah i mean you
know you you got to keep that uh
friendship oh yeah i thought yeah i
think alejandro also had talia
his students he kind of had to
oh boys
i kind of want to go with mishra cause
like you know he's the youngest gym he's
still at the top he's he's not he's a
half a point and you would make join me
on the dark side
you make christian happy to have a
little company there let's go for it
christian
and um and the lady inspired me in the
the legends and the seniors
i really want to go with larry of course
come on he's leading the tournament he's
up against a copy and today yeah but
i've also i really like his personality
i remember watching some of the
interviews i was like man he's awesome
so yeah i think i'm gonna go and since
nobody has picked him let's go for it
good joys good choice absolutely thank
you i'm gonna just jump to the game of
jennifer you for a second because i
think uh
i think you described
the whole setup for white for jennifer
very well
and how
black has to be very very careful
uh the position's even
materially speaking the positions even
but there's an imbalance the imbalance
is that white has a kingside slash
center majority
black on the other hand has a queen side
or me
a queen side majority now what
uh christensen mentioned christensen
christian i apologize
after larry i got thrown off
black does not want to
utilize her majority early like right
now she likes to
bring it later to the end game the
problem is if you move your majority too
soon this bishop
is doing is a monster bishop
so what uh
christian said
for me uh just a second let me just get
these
moves on i don't know why my
my screen is jumping everywhere
is that
from jennifer's point of view she's
going to try to use her majority she
wants to play f4 drive the queen out of
the center which she did and then she
wants to follow it up with the natural
e3 e4 bishop and suddenly white
looks like she's material ahead
because of the imbalance she's using her
majority black is not able to use hers
so it's very easy as black
to
literally fall behind and almost it
gives an appearance like you're down
you're down material because white's
playing with this extra pawn in the
center white's using her trumps
jennifer is using her majority rochelle
is not using hers and as a result she's
on the back foot
this bishop is passive
and there we see our uh production crew
uh marcus marcus batten he's the one
with the black hat the black shirt
the very nice camera but by the way
that you know it seems to be attached to
him
wherever i see marcus the guy the camera
goes with him and he's on his way to
zagreb
croatia i believe on
friday as we get ready for the grand or
uh
really a summer of chess
here in saint louis
alejandra we're talking goodness his
next break and he was like i have like
three days off in november
but that dog he goes on friday to uraija
in croatia he's going to spend a few
days as he gets ready for the zagreb
grand chest store and
i told him like think of some great
questions to
interview
magnus carlsen yeah as he joins the
grand chess tour if you had
magnus in studio today what would be a
question you'd like to ask magnus oh boy
are you gonna play
well of course but everybody's gonna ask
that i don't know i just i'm really
curious about
how he is who he is like i mean because
norway didn't really have that much
story of chess so like you know how did
he just who did you look up to hmm like
when was the moment he knew okay
i'm gonna be the world champion
does it see you gotta
alejandro is your coach you gotta feed
those kinds of questions
to alejandra so he actually
that that feels slightly betrayal that's
my new coach now i understand but i mean
you know
we we we can say to alejandra we got
these great questions for you anyway i
do like jennifer's position i do too i
like the f4 the e4 those are beautiful
but yeah they're sicilians today like
yeah this is the game of uh balaji
uh versus mishra your choice right you
went with mishra
and after knight c6
pause or
who who went into a pause the time so no
uh knight c6 uh hold on i think it's e6
okay hold on i've got to update my board
i apologize
so after knight c6 takes takes bishop c4
as you described it christian a big
fight a big fight for the deep control
over the d5 square and that is my
question right now rook g1 let's
continue fighting for that square what
about long castle and they're both
thinking pretty deeply because there are
boats below one time
an hour and 10 minutes
i'm assuming i want to move and this is
where it becomes ambitious if i go
d5 right sacrificing exchange let's go
for it it's not our pieces
exactly it's not our pieces uh
well white will be defending for quite a
while and don't forget i mean always in
the opening you have to ask a very very
salient question what am i doing with my
king
am i castling long am i castling short
and i'm leaving my king in the center
but in this exact situation
white's king has to go long
center is too dangerous king sight's
impossible but i don't think you're
going along either that's the problem
yeah yes yeah let's keep going let's
keep going so for example if you go
bishop to e2
for example yeah i don't think i'm
picking up the pawn on e4 or going d4 uh
i'm thinking actually at bishop to b4
first exactly once again setting up this
pin how do you defend against that if
you try to get away from the pin with
the move a3 then i take on c3 take on e4
and the king is not going to castle
anywhere in that position so
sorry
definitely a lot of compensation but we
do have a move
yeah sorry
christian but the position just blowed
up because
mishra just played rook takes h3
inviting
rook takes g7 and this is a different
way of fighting for the d5 square rook
check will actually force white to bring
his bishop back
so that new castle yeah so that looks so
good for white for black right right i
mean uh
black seems to have a very nice early
initiative i don't think he cannot take
on g7 i think he has to do something
else no taking on g7 maybe just set up
shop for long castle for white smoke
yeah but this kind of uh goes back to
maybe a moment like this
where
uh
you know you you might start thinking
about queen d3 and castles with or
without capturing on e6 so that
you know your your bishop's still on f1
defending h3 none of this happened he
went quick oops excuse me we went
quickly for rook takes h3
and i gotta say i
i
like black you approve of this pawn oh
big time well again because if you just
look at the activity of the pieces one
more move
castles and
black's development is complete and
you're one move and two moves away from
completing your development and black is
threatening he's got issue white's got
issues black is threatening a move like
d5
with or without knight d4
even on a good day rook takes e3
i see
mishra coming out of this opening
with the initiative i like black's
position
wow okay keep that in mind
sorry i wanted to uh jump to
uh christopher's game because we haven't
seen it for some time this was the
reverse bengal gamble
yes yes we were talking about i think we
left the summer here
exactly very early after d2d3 he took
right away takes another one and this is
actually
again we're missing alejandro because
alejandro
could speak very eloquently as to when
you should capture the pawn and when you
shouldn't
normally speaking you would prefer to
leave it
leave it as an open question whether you
want to take with the knight or take
with the bishop after a move for example
like g3 and when black plays the move
knight c6 threatening e5 then
you want to take with the bishop
but he took with the bishop right away
let's see if it makes a difference
it kind of does
and knight to d2 so now you have no
choice but to put the knight on d2
knight c6 knight b3 kind of liking
black's position if i can get e5
comfortably which i think it's up and
coming no question you're gonna get it
comfortably king this for black though
um
okay well the idea from white's point
why did white sacrifice a pawn
white sacrificed a pawn in order to
bring his rooks to the beat yes exactly
as well as the a files so let me make a
bad move for you like you don't
necessarily have to do this but now you
see you kind of get a visual of what it
is that white is banking on white is
banking on the fact that is rook
oops sorry my my mouse is everywhere
the knight
on c5 the bishop on g2
all attacking
pressuring the queen side
and it's not that easy to shake the
pressure for example a move like b6
invites queen a4 so this is what white
is hoping and uh from black's point of
view hey i'm upon up what could be bet
better e5 bishop f5 e4
and uh let's go that's a game that we
will keep our eyes on but christian um
what are the games that caught your
attention well i'm looking at this game
and its development the game between
gregory kaitanov and alexander shabolov
because once again is this bishop f4
making its uh dent into the mainstream
theory in this position after knight to
c6 it's so weird to me seeing this move
bishop to f4 it has been played compared
to bishop to e3 or knight to c3 knight
to c3 25 000 times has been played only
in these 25 000 times or in the database
in this database bishop to f4 only 20
times so you can imagine the difference
bishop to f4 once again was the
proposition of richie rapport actually
in 2021 against fabiano caruana and then
of duda against richie rapport in the
candidates tournament that just finished
bishop to f4 a6 was played and uh i
believe it was d6 the game between duda
and richie rapport e5 bishop e3 97
knight c3 knight g6 and this is where
that c5 happened on the board and
actually that gave white tremendous
advantage
alexander shabolov after quite a long
thing actually he was surprised by this
move bishop to f4 play the move a6
now let's take a look knight takes c6 c4
and it does seem like this is just
simply a better version for white
because a6 in this uh configuration
doesn't make a lot of sense doesn't help
black's position at all in my estimation
queen to d2 was played e5 bishop to e3
knight to e7 sure you do get the knight
on g6 but it seems like you have lost a
lot of tempes to get to that point queen
to f6 a6 that's already two tempes you
don't have a lot of control over the
dark squares right now so this is what
concerns me h4 after the move g3 bishop
e7 came as a thunder in the position
right now yeah sure you want to go
castle h5
get your knight to h8 and good luck
surviving what's coming on this side
look at this position how sad is this
knight on h8 definitely you cannot play
just like that and expect good results
so knight to f8 came on the board but
the way i see this position you're so
far uh
behind in development i have the two
bishops i have the better structure and
more space
and simply i don't see any attributes
that uh could sway me from giving white
a decisive advantage right now so oh
bishop to h3 is an option as well f4
i think uh gregory kaidanov is just
dominating the battle of the opening and
the ensuing the
dominating the ensuing battle of the
middle game
right now clear advantage for white
thank you for that christian i'd just
like to turn our attention for a moment
to the game between
pedro espinosa
and brandon jacobson
as uh
brandon has actually kind of climbed his
way back into contention a little bit
and
i think pedro actually misplayed it the
move queen d2 that
doesn't meet the requirements of the
position what does the position require
it requires white
to castle and get his king out of danger
knight f3 castles asp let's get it going
he played the move queen d2 and this
delay
of getting his king out of the center
was met with the move knight a5 and this
is really an awkward move
to face because you're looking at knight
b3 forking the rook and the queen but
you're also looking at
uh the potential weakness of the pawn on
c4
to deal with the thread of the fork
rook to d1 brandon said aha
now you're welcome to trade take my pawn
on d6 why did i want to get the king out
of the center
why why why why because if i don't get
the king out of the center
sometimes my king gets stuck right in
the center so
after queen c8 knight b5
pedro is hoping that brandon agrees to
making all of these trades
uh trades on uh c4
and trade trade trade and then castles
and he'll have an equal
but look at look at pedro with a shirt i
mean uh there's something
there i'm telling you lavon erodian
might be a little bit uh jealous
so i've seen some nice wardrobe on him
really he's he's throwing around the
good looks
might have nothing buy the chessboards
but i've seen some nice hawaiian
okay
um i'm looking at this position and i'm
not liking what i'm seeing as far as
pedro is concerned uh the
yes yes but it's not over and actually
the fun is just about to begin
yes that's what i meant bishop takes f3
on d6
yes
okay so first of all this would be
terrible this would be egregiously bad
bishop takes knight takes is a tempo
against the queen when the queen moves
and i'm not even sure where the queen is
supposed to move knight takes comes with
a tempo so you're welcome to grab this
rook but i'll grab this rook uh this is
not what you wanted g takes f3 is also
not what you want g takes f3 knight
takes c4 once again we are making these
trades but on black's terms
uh you see these double pawns over there
not good not good no i wish i did this
yeah exactly yeah avert your eyes this
is not the structure that you want what
about intermezzo any fun any funny
business well that's the intermezzo
right here is knight takes d6 that was
well christian
and now we have to pause because
we've got
what do we have we have all kinds of
oh my gosh um so many things i know
with the queen hanging with g2 hanging
with e2 hanging
uh
i wish i could get away with just eat g2
each h1 hc eat everything but well one
of the things that you always have to do
whatever you start calculating
is your priority is check yes you must
look at any move that delivers a check
there's no checks so that's good
so your second priority is without a
check
can we make a capture you know i've been
telling that to my students
so happy to give any confirmation well
what you can do is you can go on youtube
as they upload the stream is you can
just capture that little thing
so and and and the first captures you
look at as you know the
the biggest the queens the rooks the
knights the bishops the pawns and you
just look at the capture so uh we've
just captured a knight
we've now captured a bishop
oops that was a big girl we took a queen
we took a rook
and at the end of the day what is the
body count right
you have to do this i i go through these
calculations and it happens really
really really fast so this moment i've
got
a knight
and a rook against a queen
but because my opponent's king is still
stuck in the center i continue for a
move or two
further just to see
uh can i get something why 99 take c4
knight takes c4
because is this knight trapped i'd also
look at rook e8
and let me just go you guys are good man
i'll give you that
that was in fact the best variation is
go for sure
yes no you guys are good i mean
directionally at least you know what
you're doing i have to say knight takes
e6 bishop takes it to look for the
captures right and calculate the most
critical variation and forced variation
right
exactly
queen takes the eight knight takes c4
castle rook ae8 and you will see later
on why this is the best movie in the
position knight to d5 knight takes d5
queen takes d5 knight takes c3 f takes
it once again liquidation liquidation
and now imagine this rook from f8 would
be on e8 instead of that you would have
a hanging pawn and a weakened pawn on f7
not only that but the rook on a8 would
be the target of white's queen so now
you understand what
rook a28 accomplished this is the
position most likely that we're going to
see after rook to g8 it does seem like
white doesn't have much more than just a
simple equality black's position is just
simply to save and you don't have as
black any structural weaknesses and this
is exactly what the queen needs to
dominate these type of imbalances that's
not the case right now this position is
completely equal knight to d6 is on the
board now
bishop takes two is one way knight to e4
is another one and then knight takes
very interesting lights right not not
the typical queen move that you would
expect just to get out of uh this attack
queen to c7 or queen to e6 actually it
does seem like uh white is going to be
better after just the simple bishop
takes f3 recapturing the piece so knight
to e4 knight takes c8 knight takes d2
once again we calculate the most forced
variations g takes f3 knight takes c4
this is the position that we need to
assess the computer is saying that the
position is somewhat equal
maybe a slight pull for white
specifically after the move b4 you have
to defend the pawn on b uh to with a
tempo
knight takes e3 take on e5 take on a5 or
take on e3
very complicated battle even in this end
game but a lot of the pieces are getting
liquidated so
this is definitely what i think pedro
wants to see from this position a
slightly better position uh and not a
lot of pieces left remaining on the
board for brandon to complicate matters
with so i think brandon after knighto
excuse me pedro after knight takes d6
should be quite happy with the outcome
of the opening remember that pedro as he
entered into the free day did have a
victory over carissa very very nice uh
win so his
his sales have a little wind and we'll
keep an eye on that as we prepare for
break it's our time to tell
everybody about cue boutique torso yes
yes what's our special today well it
seems to be a very very cute
that is it yep
four inch black modern tulip
chess sets
yeah
it's very unique it's kind of modern
twist on a traditional handcrafted uh it
is from ebony and boxwood
and it's kind of a
15 weight yes 15 and half inch
with two inch squares it is online and q
boutiques and lewis.com
and
fun fact tulip in
middle eastern countries like turkey
iran is the the um
the flower of the royal
really it's the national flower of
holland too the tulips yes yes holland
is and i know here they're very pricey
they're royal
so it's like holland and malaysia are
two of the great flower growing
countries of the world and you think
that holland is very small no no no no
they have fields of flowers gorgeous
gorgeous we're going to see you on the
other side of the break as round six of
the national
championships continue
[Music]
how did you uh prepare for this event we
know it's a very prestigious event what
was your training routine coming into
this map i've been studying chess
a lot
since the epidemic started
and basically u.s senior role is in my
mind
this is like the main goal
basically for the last six months i i'm
thinking about this while i'm studying
chess i didn't have much time to prepare
because
i
just came from europe where i played for
us
national team or senior team in the
world championship as always nothing
changed i
played some tournaments before so that
to
warm up
to be ready of course some some
preparation
like always
this is a professional professional life
of chess player something nothing
special for this
event was kind of trying to convince my
managers and my my wife and my family
that that's something that you know i
should be doing and once they got on
board i am basically just
trying to look up who is going to play
and basically
find
something to encourage myself that i can
i can fight those people
basically playing non-stop it's a little
bit different tactic that i used to so
i just got back from italy and i played
for the us team at the world seniors and
then i played the world open right after
that
so basically i played for the last three
weeks non-stop okay so getting back
reviewing what's uh the top games in the
world what the opening strategies are
when i
see what colors i have against my
opponent then i'll get to spend some
time trying to work out how the openings
are going to go there nothing special
you know just as usual we watch the
games and trying to analyze and train to
think um
that's it nothing unusual you know
the main thing is i think in these
tournaments you want to be as lord as
possible at all times you know could go
four or five hours of hard intense
concentration and i found the worst
thing you can do and i've done this so
many times is to
cram for
big games
staying up till four in the morning you
know
over preparing and just wearing yourself
out i'll try to avoid that this time
well you know life gets in the way of
things so i've been doing a lot of
things uh you know i'm not a full-time
professional player anymore so um you
know maybe i have a little catch-up to
do but i think that's probably true for
most of the players
so i i think it really comes down to you
know which which player you know summons
up the energy to fight in the in the in
the fourth hour it remains to be seen
but whether what i have done was
actually what i was supposed to be doing
but uh
let's
let's not speak too much about it for
now
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to our live
coverage of the national championships
dorsa let's take a look at the pairing
starting with the girls championships
what games do you have for us our
marquee match-ups if you will we've seen
some really really nice games so far
i feel like a very interesting game is
the jennifer eugene sister show blue
game right because jennifer is just a
point behind and as we've talked about
it before she is facing so he's um
maureen suzuki tomorrow right so if she
does win this and sophie does not end up
winning her game today it could be a
really nice fight for jennifer tomorrow
uh another key matchup that we've been
looking at has been sophie's uh maurice
suzuki's game versus um roy young yan
absolutely and then the junior yes
well we've been talking a lot about the
justin wang game versus christopher yu
so that has been a very interesting
match but i also have to say i'm very
interested to see how my recently picked
[Laughter]
mishra ended up doing in his today
against
and of course christopher you against
justin wang that's been the um reverse
bengal gambit that's been a cool game
and of course in the seniors
it's about larry christensen our
tournament leader of course he is facing
the highest rated and also the newcomer
of the 50-plus
vladimir
right yeah
so that's also going to be a very very
nice mashup now another one that could
be real fun just from the games that
we've been seeing was um we were talking
about this one game who was it uh
gregory
guy donna versus alexander schneiderlin
that's the position i'm really liking
that position yeah that was at a very
unusual
um open sicilian with a bishop f4 that
we saw that
uh christian duda played in the
uh candidates so there you see a very
nice
picture of all of the playing hall and
that's just one side
on the other side
and all the players are mixed too it's
not like just you know the seniors
against the wall over here the girls
against all over there it used to be
though yeah i know and i like this mix i
mean it's sort of like when you get up
and you go around and see the games and
the i spoke with the seniors and they're
all like really happy to see the juniors
because it's inspiring to see the
juniors and the girls there they've been
swinging for the fences and that's why
we get these big big score
big big scores uh in their games just
having the game justin
wang
against uh christopher you for just a
moment we just had this move knight d7
it might look a little bit strange
to drop the knight back like that but
the idea behind this move is actually to
prep
b7 b6 and bishop to b7
and with the move knight d7 the pawn on
d4 is further protected so in other
words you might say okay i'll play b6
but then you know i'm giving up yes i'm
giving up my monster bishop but i am
winning back the pawn and i'm doing so
with the tempo so the move knight d7 is
kind of what you want to do is
neutralize this long square
long
diagonal bishop with a move b7 b6 and
bishop b7 now if you can get in those
two moves black will not only have a
pawn in the pocket but
white's pieces will actually have
difficulty finding good squares and i'm
thinking you should
probably
trade off a pair of knights right away
knight c5 takes takes and again you get
this very
usual
well-known benko
gambit kind of pressure for the pawn and
by getting rid of that knight on a d7
you're opening up the b file for the
rook so that's something to keep in mind
one game that blew up during our break
was the game of uh
wunder liang
versus david brodsky when we left it it
was all very conventional stuff with g7
g5 a ton of games
has gone like this i told you about by
catching themselves story so all of this
is pretty standard stuff
help me out
where is that like trying to go i mean i
get it that's the knight is i thought
mighty one uh black wanted to whiten
wanted to play pawn f4 and he does he
does all right
and he just thought
yeah well by by bringing the knight to
d3 you're thinking you're going to play
pawn f4 yes
but then maybe you want to recapture
with the knight
as well as the bishop in the meantime
by also uh when as soon as black put his
bishop on this diagonal one of the
things you start to think about is black
is let's break up the team
the d4 e5 team
let's break up that team by playing pawn
to c5 hence knight to d3 is kind of like
i'm going to shut you down over here i
don't want to see you play c5 in the
meantime i want to play f4 so this
battle of ideas brewing b7 b6
c2 c3
c5 look at this clash this is really
good stuff
knight drop back f4
c4
let's sacrifice
take my knight please if you take i'm
going to take another pawn
and then when you drop back with your
bishop
let's say i've picked up three pawns
i'm not even sure i need to take this
pawn by the way i've picked up three
pawns and the king is really
exposed
a wonder said i'm not interested in your
knight
takes f6
takes
and david said you know what if i take
this pawn
your king has no pawn shield
bishop takes knight to e4
bishop back to e3
uh
i'm not feeling it here unless unless a
wonder can bring his knight very quickly
to f5
he's going to have a real hard time
proving
compensation because black's king
is a little scary
bishop yeah
thank you
okay so what uh what we're thinking is
that uh
bishop takes g5 bishop back to bishop g5
back to e3 you got to start thinking
how how how do i get my pieces
over to the king side right this knight
on e7 desperately needs to go to f5 and
if i could play knight f5 and queen h4
might get some uh
um
compensation but christian jump right in
here should black be playing for e5 no
for knight to f5 and like f5 yes with
the idea of a bishop to g6
so bishop to g 666
also putting some pressure on the f file
right because your rook on a1 still
cannot contend for uh dominance on the f
file so you still have some uh moves to
make until you can bring that rook to
the other side of the board next to the
king so exactly bishop to g6 i really
like this move quite a key move to
maintain the balance and in fact the
assessment after bishop to g6
it seems that black has enough
compensation for at least a balanced
position and equality yes yes after
bishop to g6
this reminds me by the way we've seen a
big game between
lenier dominions with the white pieces
and levon aronian during the american
cup when levon ironian played probably
for the first time uh in his life the
karo khan and he put some pressure with
the black pieces this exactly this is
exactly what we're seeing in this game
as well this pawn sacrifice nevertheless
i have a very strong knight on e4 and
another one joining the fray via f5 a
lot to be played for still in this
position nothing is concluded now
brandon jacobson i have to say
is spending a lot of time on his
decision right now knight week or bishop
takes e2 and go into that end game
without the queen now
i want to catch you up with this guy
this game between andrew hung and
carissa yip
because carissa ip right now well i mean
she did get the knight to b4 but after
the move castle where is this night
going all i could see a
potential trajectory for the knight is
knight to c2 followed by knight to d4
the problem is that you have to first
open uh this diagonal for the bishop to
support and move knight to c2 knight to
e4 was played but what if i just simply
take take and go bishop to g3 i don't
want to take on d6 now
why don't i don't why don't i want to
take on d6
most probably because of the move rook
to f5
and now knight to e3 unfortunately to
defend the pawn on d5 doesn't work
because the bishop d6 is just simply
hanging so i will recapture on d5 and it
does seem like that gives my pieces
enough uh cooperation and enough
activity to be just a fine position for
a black knight to e4 good move by
karissa but what if you just take take
and go bishop to g3
how are you going to play at this
position i want to take on d6 but i want
to take on d6 with the knight that also
is going to open up this square for my
bishop to jump to c4 it just feels like
white has more harmony uh infused in his
pieces right now karissa's still in
trouble but it doesn't feel like white
got that grip like maybe not that much
if you continue this line and let's just
say bishop takes d5
knight takes d6 bishop to d4 yes yes i'm
kind of thinking you know
i mean
a a moment ago i was really
feeling
is very concrete right so if you manage
to stabilize the position as black if
you get a queen on d7 or something
right if you manage to stabilize then
black species are looking nice but do
you have time to do that to b5 okay do
you have time to do that i was i was
yeah i was being a pawn grubber i was
going after the pawn on b2 absolutely
absolutely right
again it's a matter of speed right now
you go back to g7 then i have ideas of
knight to c7 or bishop d6 the position
remains very complicated nevertheless
indeed the trajectory of the last few
moves and we saw at the beginning of the
game uh at the in the opening phase
white was just crushing
and at that particular position right
now it does seem like risa has developed
her pieces and is getting closer to uh
establishing that balance in the
position and another big game that i was
having my eyes on yeah and maybe you
guys can take it from here is this one
between alice lee and talia because
talia is one point behind the leader
sophie maurice suzuki and check this out
we said b6 was not a particularly good
move
this was the reason knight to g5
immediately asked questions not only
that but take advantage of the
consequences of the move b6 one of the
biggest consequences that this diagonal
has opened up so for example right now
if you follow it up with queen to d5
bishop e2 would be a big problem bishop
b2 followed by bishop to f3 you cannot
defend the bishop on e6 and the pawn on
c4 like that so you have to go bishop to
d5 but then i continue with e4 and once
again after bishop to b7 bishop takes c4
this is starting to look really good for
white you have to castle nevertheless it
does feel like i got what i wanted i
have a beautiful center the development
is coming up nicely
is definitely looking like white has
established um dominance in the position
so
h4 was actually what was played in the
game
by alice lee but unfortunately for her
after h6 h5
g5 it does seem like
this whole sequence favors a black let's
take a look at why castle bishop takes
g7 king takes g7 knight to e5
c5 a very good move by talia knight
takes c4n i understand you eliminated my
dark square bishop right but we look at
the pawn structure and all the pawns are
on the dark squares how are you going to
get
to my king on g7 do you have enough
pieces it doesn't look like you do you
no longer have as white the dark square
bishop either and what i do have well i
have a big lead in development as black
i will go queen to c7 your knight on c4
is a little bit shaky you have to drop
back
to uh d2 if you try to stay in the
center thank you very much i'm winning
some more time with the move knight to
d7 another tempe in the position and
after you castle i'm looking at this
pawn on h5 is it a strength or a
liability
my answer to that question is
in the future this pawn on h5 is going
to become a liability for white so
that's why i think the sequence that
we've seen in the past few moves
definitely favors talia
wow okay uh that's
that's very good obviously for
uh italia and i let's go to the game of
sophia for just a moment because again
talia's chasing the tournament leader
who is leading by a full point
and let's see what's going on here so
when we left it
we we saw uh rue yang yan giving up her
dark squared bishop
a maneuver we really didn't like but she
had an immediate follow with the move
c4 c5
she's
eyeballing this pawn on asa a6
let me play bishop takes a6 and capture
the pawn takes on c5 now
doubtlessly you know she's got uh roo
yang has uh
she she uh captured on c5 but you've
also got to calculate like what would
happen if i play bishop takes
a6 because
does that come with a tempo i think she
declined it not 100 sure i think she
must have declined it
from this exchange sacrifice maybe there
was something about this exchange
sacrifice
that she did yeah
so she didn't take on asic recapture
with the knight bishop takes
pawn takes
okay even though
my pawns are split that does give me the
leverage i need maybe to establish a
rook on d6 by the way
uh
uh
queen
b8 to a7 an invitation to trade pawns do
you want to take my pawn on h4 i'll take
your pawn on c5 with check no thank you
said rue yang
that just feels like
a little unnatural to me why not that i
just gonna queen b3
i could try to eat the other pawn
perhaps sure or like well i'm i want to
try to activate the rest of my pieces
because queen a7 i mean
it has a clear threat but
i feel like it's a little too obvious
and knight day 2 or
anything else to just defend that c5
pawn
would come pretty naturally as well but
queen b3 now you're kind of questioning
all right opponent
are you sure you want to eat on h4 are
you sure you want to eat on asics what
do you want to do right
i would probably
kick the queen i don't like this queen
landing on my doorstep i would probably
offer a queen trade so that if you did
take something similar to the game i'm
trying white at least is trying to get
the knight to b4 to lift the blockade
of the bishop on c6 if i can go c5 c67
i'm i'm gold
and i suspect queen a2 and again i
kind of am telegraphing my punches i
want to play queen a2 rook d6 if you go
back with the queen well then i can
you know if you do if you uh refuse to
trade fair maybe something like this but
it does relieve the pressure up of my
age for a pawn at least of course i
agree with that wholeheartedly
queen a7 maybe not such a good move i'm
not
quite sure myself knight a2 i like what
white is doing pawn goes to h3 we talked
a moment about
the game of alice lee
upon on h5
christian said it's going to be a future
liability upon on h3 i would suspect
after g3 this pawn on h3 is uh all but a
goner
uh long term
uh but uh okay uh
our tournament leader
just a little bit on the back foot i
feel uh at this moment and guys yes that
opens uh the possibility of jennifer you
potentially catching up with the leader
if sophie morris suzuki loses right this
game so let's take a look at what
happened in that game and if you were
here from the beginning of the broadcast
we were talking a lot about
this knight on d4 and why instead of
bishop to e7 bishop to c5 initially was
the better alternative also at some
point we mentioned especially at the
beginning
this idea of playing the move d3 first
and not bishop to g2 now for example if
you go
uh bishop to c5 take on e4 take on a4
bishop to g2 knight takes e3 and we were
giving this as an improvement for white
because this knight on d4 right now is
uh cemented in the center the b file is
open for a potential attack on the b
file as well and it just feels like
white species are better now let's take
a look at what happened
in this game
h3 this is where we left it off and now
rochelle played the move bishop to b4
not going after the knight on d4 but
actually going after knight on c3 but
we've seen this if you do take on c3
that's actually going to improve my
position right if you take it with the
knight on f6 if you take it with your
dark square bishop and also relinquish
the two bishops well that's actually
going to improve my position as white
even more so this is what's happening
right now it feels like rochelle just
simply doesn't understand what she needs
to do in the position and i have to say
after b6 rook fd1 it just feels like
white's pieces are are just simply much
better once you play the move c5 i'm
going to have another square that i can
target it with my knight knight b5
knight c3 knight to d5 these two knights
beautifully defending each other
nevertheless
they're also called superfluous nights
because this knight on f6 doesn't really
seem to have a job anymore right exactly
except defending and also potentially
could become uh the part of an attack
after g4 g5 right so
i'm seeing this bishop dominant bishop
on the long diagonal the bishop on b2
and i'm seeing the superfluous knights i
feel like white has developed
its initiative quite nicely and jennifer
you is definitely in poor position to
potentially catch up with the leader
absolutely
and here are our standings coming into
this round six sophia mora suzuki with a
perfect five out of five jennifer you
talia cervantes chasing her down a point
behind
uh
and uh both jennifer and talia's
position
i have to say a little bit better for
them all right i feel like
it's more comfortable jennifer's
position most especially because i like
i'll just show
what flashed through my eyes a kind of a
combination
that instantly got my attention is once
you see this bishop you kind of go
that's like really really really nice
yeah exactly and you start thinking to
yourself no you can't get away with this
type of thing as
as black um so i
i like jennifer's uh position a lot
where would you like to take this please
it's not exactly just right
okay uh were you ever in a situation
that you or you're playing like your
best friend or like you know blood
relative or whatever and you're just
like
man i love you so much i just can't
attack you
right no no first of all i like to say
that
whatever
mistakes you can make in chess
i've made them at least twice
just to be sure
that it was a mistake the first time
around right you know like i don't just
blunder my queen to a discover check the
first time i do it a second and a third
just to make sure just to make sure
and so everything that could possibly go
wrong in chess has gone wrong for me
wonderful exactly including just what
you said uh i've always had extreme
difficulty playing against somebody i
would call a brotherhood pairing you
know i once i once went on a
summer's tour in 1975 with a dear friend
uh bomber
bill mcgarry uh we went on this summer
from seattle to san diego to las vegas
to lincoln nebraska and it was like we
played each other
every time every tournament
it was awful it was awful i hated
uh that aspect to chess playing a
pairing that you least won oh yes and
and i really really really suffered
later
i kind of as i matured as a person it
was like look i love you you know
everything's good
and we're just playing again we're just
playing a tough game and whoever wins
you know buys dinner
right i mean that's the way it goes i i
always pair to play my brothers in like
three different tournaments your brother
oh this time the first one we played you
know seriously but i was playing
seriously because i was you know like
about to get my like seventh w i am not
okay uh no i i was on my win um title
hunt so i was playing seriously and then
he just he was just like i just couldn't
play so like i just couldn't think and
he's younger than me so the next time we
played
um i couldn't think so i was just like i
was black and i was thinking and i was
like oh my god i'm just gonna play
something defensive if he wants to
attack he can attack but i'm just gonna
and then he wouldn't attack and i
wouldn't
and the same thing happened when i
played one of mine
yeah i i played one of my best friends a
few years back in like your like world
junior championship and i was like oh
god i'm black again like i don't want to
attack she doesn't want to attack and
after the game it had it in a draw we
played like a dead draw like queen's
camp the queen is indian like everything
locked up
so i guess what i'm trying to you know
um
also think about this like a lot of
these uh kids a lot of these juniors and
girls are friends with each other so
it's really hard to actually compete
against your friends and you know want
to like beat them up exactly
yeah
they're doing a great job but still for
me it's
i need some time to get over that i
don't know if i'm still over that but
right all right kristen uh jump in how
do you handle what we in seattle used to
call the brotherhood pairings uh
playing against somebody you really is
you you is it's your best bud oh i play
so much better
i
i want to beat them so hard
but that
only gives me one extra point but it
also gives me bragging rights wow in
that relationship for the next uh i
don't know one year until we meet each
other right
leaving your your best friend in tears
no problem with that you know yeah let's
buy them dinner or drink or something
it's just about the bragging rights you
know because we like to trash talk a lot
i beat you so many times in that i
dominated you and whatnot and this is
the type of relationship that i have
with my friends and they say the same
thing we like to trash talk a lot so a
victory is like friends
i lose my friends dude
by the way while we were talking uh
sophie
understood
that her position was actually
becoming desperate because essentially
white is ready just to play bishop takes
retreat with a bishop have a pawn in the
pocket and again night before is
breaking a blockade so sophia lashed out
with a p sacrifice bishop takes e4 i'm
anticipating well thank you very much
i'm going to take that piece
knight takes e4 well if knight takes e4
that might be just
terrible uh queen e3 i was i was about
to uh look at this piece sacrifice but
that's three points but maybe she has a
better way maybe better idea of knight
to g4 yeah
queen got a move it could get actually
pretty interesting
hmm
i'll have to clean it up
bishop takes e4
i'm i'm really okay i'm afraid of rook
takes c5 fair so let's look at clean c2
because if not anything else c5 goes
away exactly now i'm ready to take this
pawn and so let's look at 93
but now
still c5 c5 is hanging
i'm not getting the very nice two pieces
and the crazy part is if
no you could take this
but you could also go back
uh bishop takes e4 have we
have we missed this as a tactic
christian we did not no no good bishop
takes c4 is well actually we did yes we
did never mind forget about what i just
said we did and white did as well or
maybe did not understand all the nuances
black seems to be doing just fine now
not more than just equality but
check this equality out so bishop take
c4 take only for knight g4 this is the
variation that's the key we were looking
at now you have to be extremely precise
as white and is very difficult
easy to stray away for example queen to
c2 makes a lot of sense you defend the
pawn on c5 right after knight to e3
you're in big trouble in fact this
position after queen to f2 knight takes
d1 rook takes d1 queen takes e5 or rook
takes c5
this is despite the fact that you have
two pieces for a rook and a couple of
pawns
and you're getting one back
unfortunately you get one back on h3 you
do have the double pawns your pieces are
just all over the place they're not very
well coordinated and we are about to
enter an end game and we know that once
the queens are traded off the two-piece
the two pieces against the rook in the
end game the rook becomes a bit stronger
so
now let's take a look at potentially
queen to e2 in this position allow rook
take c5 and now queen takes a6 now this
makes a lot of sense why not right if
you take on a6 i will take back with the
bishop and this is there goes your
attack it's winning for a while right
easily uh winning now rook takes c1
comes on the board queen
and we go into this variation in which
after knight to c3 rook to c1 or rook to
a1 how do we assess at this position
there's a very
unpleasant bind
on the king side
this
pin on the first rank is going to be
very difficult to get away from um i'm
seeing the position i'm seeing the
assessment which is saying 0-0-0
but from a practical perspective i have
to say i would be quite uh concerned if
i was white i would start looking for
any sort of perpetuals against the rook
on e8 for example queen to d7 you try to
run away i go queen to c7 and so on and
so forth so
still a very complicated battle right
now also you have to be careful rook to
b2 is coming
so for example rook to b to his
potential move in the position rook to
a8 apparently the assessment is saying
that once the queen is on c7 this is
already winning for black wow so you
have to be super careful bishop to e4
was the right move now
instead of g3 it seems like g4 would
have been better the idea being if you
take now i go g5
i don't take on e4 i go g5 first there's
no more knight landing on a g4
disrupting
this control that i have given by the
queen on f2 on the a7 g1 diagonal
there's no more attack coming against my
king on g1 this is looking good for
white so
g4 was a big big move in the position
creating some unpleasant
in black's camp so unfortunately she did
not find this bishop takes e4 is on the
board 37 minutes for rue yang 52 for
sophie mori suzuki this is and was a big
moment in the game yeah instead of uh g4
because g4 felt like i mean if you don't
see g3 bishop takes e4 i don't think g4
is something you think about so how
about instead of touching the g pawn
what about knight b4 because knight is
on a2 go to b4 knight before was a good
move yes that's the one piece i know
where i want to put so maybe let's do
that first
i i also uh tend to agree with you dorsa
in this one knight to d4 at least from a
practical perspective is definitely the
move that creates the most problems in
black's position because now you would
once again love to keep this bishop on
this diagonal and try to get some bishop
to 84 at some point
working but what you have to do is go
bishop to a4 and then you have to
contend with rook to d6 ideas and how to
defend on this side i really like this
sequence that you are proposing knight
to b4 followed by rook to d6 you take on
g2 that's fine i will take back on g2
and you don't have enough pieces to
create a huge attack on the king side
nevertheless from a strategical point of
view i also have to be careful because
if you manage to stabilize as black the
queen side and get the knight to f4 in
the absence of the g pawn the knight on
f4 is just going to be cemented on that
very aggressive square so i don't want
to see a knight landing on f4 this is
what i'm saying uh very intriguing
position guys absolutely i just want to
take a quick look at the alice lee
versus telia cervantes game because i i
mean this is almost a dream come true
for grunfeld defense players and it's so
weird
for me to see this type of position
normally in a grunfeld knight f3 bishop
e2 castles or bishop c4 92 castles
white's king is vacated the center it's
almost you know you almost never see a
queen so dominantly positioned
as
it is currently with the um king still
in the center of the board after queen
c3 there's no way that white can really
tolerate this queen for much longer
you've got to play queen c1
and
you know uh go into some kinds of
endings which grunfell players are very
happy to play especially with the pawn
on h5 it looks good for
talia but also check the last few moves
uh oh yes sir
go through the last few moves oh every
single move improves black's position
while white is on the defensive end
knight to e5 knight to c4 backwards
queen to c7 knight to d2 backwards queen
to c3 now you have to hunt my queen to
exchange it everything just seems to be
going in black's favor exactly all the
the entirety of the last sequence i the
trend as we say the trend is the friend
of black here and oh that's a big
surprise for me jennifer
after the move rook d1 bishop d7 i'll go
along with that that's okay but jennifer
made a move i would really
not have made myself
knight to b3 i always like
when i'm seeing this diagonal i i mean
that's a clarion excuse me that's a
clarion call for me
to be attacking like i
would really much rather
position my knight in the center of the
board
where it's
defended defended by the pawn on f4
defended by the bishop on
knights improve
the more they're defended and the move
knight be
d4 be
that that that strikes me as a voluntary
retreating move
i'm not can't play c5 after that and
just
let it maybe she has some ideas based on
bishop takes so like if you do play pawn
c5 and i'm not saying it's a bad move uh
there is
something you may have to contend with
like i could take
and if you take with the knight well i'm
winning an exchange maybe i'm not happy
about the exchange but well it is an
exchange
uh and if you take with a pawn well
i'm not sure you're happy about getting
your
king side all right i'm very happy with
my knights though i understood i
understand um
but uh for me to my eyes christian
uh
jennifer needs to work on her attacking
skills the move knight b3 is a step in
my opinion away from the action
yes your eyes are definitely not
deceiving you
yeah sir knight to b3 is not the right
direction exactly knight to b3 probably
knight to f3 was in fact the best move
in the position at least according to
the engines and it makes a lot of sense
because not only that you're eyeing that
e5 square but maybe even knight g5 at
some point to change the character of
the position open up uh things in uh
that way that fashion
definitely knight to f3 would have been
the better try now if you want to go to
d2 right because that's the only reason
why you would play the move knight to b3
right destabilize the knight on e4 why
wouldn't you do it from f3 exactly it
just has so much more potential on f3
and this is something that we as players
and as grandmasters we like to maximize
whenever possible potential of our
pieces knight to f3 was the right
approach knight to b3
assessment wise it is in fact
black who is better right now whoa
after the move c5 not an easy move to uh
c by the way because you do allow the
move bishop takes f6 right takes f6
would allow me to take on a8 and that's
just going to give me a winning
advantage that's fair
but
if you do take with the g pawn on the
other hand and once again
this is not easy this is not easy to
play c5 and allow bishop takes f6 this
is what i'm
saying right now but once you take on f6
the king is quite safe in fact not only
that but after the move f4 we see a
weakness on g3 how do you get to that
weakness well potentially king to h8
followed by rook to g8 now that the g5
is open so
this position still remains very complex
rochelle
does need to find the move c5
big big position big moment for these
two ladies and let's not forget rochelle
is on three points if she wins this one
she will equalize the score of jennifer
you jennifer is on four out of five
points if she wins this one well
potentially we'll get closer to sophie
mori suzuki
with a big direct clash between those
two players coming up tomorrow
absolutely absolutely but christian if i
may ask you the question
uh the move c6 c5 exposing the rook in
the corner that's the question
why is c5 necessary and why not move the
rook
first yes you can also play c5 you can
also do go rook 88 then i would assume
this is what she wanted this is what
jennifer wants yeah yeah well again it's
it's not the best it's still not the
best it could have been much better
after this move knight to f3 knight to
e5 right this is not the right way uh
the right direction for white rook takes
d2 and now i can go bishop to f5 once
again take a lot of um control over the
square e4 potentially offering the trade
of the bishops with the move bishop e4
in the future
it's complicated it remains complicated
three results right now and uh it does
seem like slowly but
surely rochelle is getting back into the
game okay very good we'll keep our eyes
on on those developments what do you
have for us what culture i was just
looking at our legends uh the leader
larry playing versus well another
potential leader right
and i realized that um you know what way
i mean the vacuum
cleaner came on the board and yep yeah
okay so we left it way way way back
after finish five i was cleaning you're
talking about it and you were like well
queen what if those coins get
which is exactly what happened
bishop went back to these interesting
that larry played bishop e3 i might have
been anxious to try d5 myself bishop e3
knight
to
d3
cam and just trying to get uh the zen of
what's going on here
that's a funny way of uh usually in an
isolated uh queen pond position you
don't see a central pond duo and
suddenly by the way guys c5 is on the
board in that game
what's on the board c5 is on the board
named jennifer use game oh
not rook take root no not rook the a the
best move c5
and we're in a
very intriguing
night ending
normally speaking night endings
so much in the night endings are about
past pawns that are
further away from the center
but oftentimes night ending is also
about activity specific specifically the
kings and we can see that white is just
played the move king e3
thinking about
king e4 d5 and on a good day the king
would trot
right down the long diagonal i'm quite
the happy with white's position
with the space yeah space the pawn
structure
the king activity the potential for the
night everything seems to be just
but if i could
get in
wow uh
king
i don't know should i maybe i should be
playing with my knight instead i'm
i'm a little bit unsure about this
position uh
it does feel like white's for choice i
just
don't know if it's how much yeah if it's
severe or not at the moment and it might
just be happening that uh
sometimes when you do get in the move d5
let me just put a move on the board for
just a moment
that sometimes you just kind of
hit a um
a door
although this king
does dominate hmm
definitely a a game we want i want to
keep an eye on i just also wanted to
take a look at some of our
um
players in second place who are doing
very well dmitry gurvich versus nick
defermion
uh
two bishops but wait a minute he
dima has sacrificed upon
f4 and
nick is saying
show me
you know yes i understand you've got a
bishop and you've got a good night
but
two bishops rook
king h1 should be better for white uh
joe benjamin uh pardon me max delugey
versus joe benjamin oh what what
happened the time block had 17 minutes
what
go one more
one more
17 minutes
boy joel uh really down on the clock and
an awkward position too uh white's
majority is very very nice the knight
kind of got stuck
on c6
here i like white's advantage can we
take on b7
can we take on b7 i don't know i i
stopped just because i saw the movement
of b8 but there is no rook takes c6 i
was thinking but that that one is also a
move yeah
rook takes c6
wow
rook takes c6 i think rook b7 is the
only move right okay and then rook takes
e6 bishop takes f3 and hope that bishop
e2 puts me in an awkward position and
maybe it does
maybe it does yeah this looks like it's
okay for black
for a moment there i mean it visually
rook takes c6 looks like a cruncher
but yeah i think it's okay but then
again your question right what about
bishop takes d5 right
but perhaps this is not the best you can
get as why right rook takes b7 on bishop
takes c6 rook b8 and we get into this
end game
we know that white probably doesn't have
any problems and maybe even slightly
better
but not much more than that
yeah um okay we'll keep an eye on that
and finally igor we
how could we not go to the two eagles i
mean you you got igor
uh novikov uh who's been playing well
and by the way um
what's interesting is in all of the
discussions the interviews as the
seniors come up and they talk about
their games they're oftentimes saying
igor novikov is like the premier expert
and he knows so many variations of the
najdorf that they really respect
his preparation so for those of you who
are watching the show who want to play
the night or you might want to
take a look at igor novikov's games and
use him as a guide
because
everybody who's come out here and spoke
about
uh their games with him uh
have nice things to say about his uh
theoretical knowledge we saw so many g
and h pawns flying today
and then finally and i did want to turn
to christian on this one because this
game between craig gregory kady kaidanov
pardon me greg and uh shabba dabba doo
alexander chaballo has blowed up and
this is a crazy position uh going on
here what's going on christian this is
mean what just happened black is
completely busted forward
for a while now but to be honest really
white had an even better opportunity
right now he played the move c5 okay
good move decent move uh keeps the
advantage in white's cam but bishop
takes c6 was actually decisive
right now it seems like this is a plus
3.1 advantage
if you take with any of the pawns
especially with the d-pawn queen to d6
he invades rook to b8 rook queen takes
c6 this is over right you cannot do that
you have to take with the queen exactly
now
queen to d3 now
this is a three-pawn advantage it's a
three pawn advantage and
only with perfect moves by black because
for example if you play something like
castle check this out
f5 let's go let's keep going where do
you put the queen you don't have where
to put the queen that's the problem you
go queen e7 b4 is coming in the position
bishop to c7 bishop to c5 comes in the
position as well this is just simply
dominant every single move is coming
with tempo and let's take a look at if
you do something else for example
instead of um castle castle maybe you
start with the move queen e7 just take
on f4 you open up the g file
thank you very much
yasser i
know you have a death wish i mean come
on f5 queenie
queen e5 yes let's go i gotta check you
congratulations
i want you more than just uh
i want to participate congratulations
you gave me a check
what else what is your attack you have
nothing i don't know i mean uh
recognition of excellence
[Laughter]
why yes sir
terrible terrible it's over wow but even
the position that we have right now it's
not that easy nevertheless
black is
having something well that's what i
thought that is that it was unclear
okay the current position okay i agree
that bishop takes e6
would have been maybe uh
instead of c4 c5 i mean
but the current position
get give us some insight is it still
like
plus three
it's plus 1.6 that's pretty decent
okay and uh give us some lines uh
christian please
what would you like uh to do as white
and uh
you you
start me start me off right how how how
do you continue right now do you take on
e5 because
there's a big moment right now you can
change the character of the position by
taking on e5 right the structure is
changed uh you can also go queen to d6
change the character of the position
like that that maybe is the most
conservative approach and try to go into
a much better end game that's one way of
doing things you can go bishop take c6
and
strive for variations that we've seen
previously the problem is just
once you take take now
this diagonal is open so now i can
invade with the queen via b3 so that
might be a bit problematic okay go back
i i would find myself drawn to the move
b4 b4 all right continue like this
bishop c7 and knight to d5 whoo-hoo yes
yes because i'm you're playing nice
chess but at the same time losing your
advantage
i wanted to play d5 d6 dude work with me
on this one i'll take i'll take i have
to take with the pawn no
i'm not going to move my knight
oh
i'm going to invite you you you you you
got off the d6 yeah and now i'm starting
to take advantage of your weakness i
played in the 24 i played you you did
play the move b4 and c5 you weaken the
king a little bit so you have to be
careful
wow
he's still in the game this is what i'm
seeing from uh this uh last few moves
sequence
alex chabalov was pretty much dead if
bishop ac6 would have come on the board
right now he's still in the position
still in this game and the clock
situation is quite close 31 minutes for
kaidanov 32 minutes for alex chabala but
i have to say kaidanov doesn't feel like
he's in his best shape
in this tournament he has been drawing
all his games actually 50
right now but he did not manage to
convert any of his advantages he didn't
get into much trouble himself either
nevertheless he's not himself it feels
like
right
all right well thank you for that i
wanted to pick up because we kind of
left off with christopher you for just a
moment our tournament leader in the
juniors he's had a phenomenal result
four and a half out of five he's up
against justin wang when we left it i we
just seen the move knight d7 lots of
moves have been played in that game i
was expecting knight to c5 to in
anticipation of b7 b6 rook fb1 b7 b6
c5 and justin took a completely
different approach
takes takes
and bishop takes e7 nice rook takes and
he has to maintain this pin otherwise
the bishop is hanging but christopher
wait a minute wait a minute i got
i got my shots too
queen e7 as well as queen takes e2 on
tap and we are catching up to the
players
um
and once again as is so often the case
in these benko gambits
uh even though we're in an ending we're
black as a pawn up white he has got this
nasty little
threat of knight to d6
in combination with the bishop
is it enough for the pawn
your
cake
would you rather have the initiative or
would you rather have the paul i'm not a
pawn eater you're not upon you you you
like you you would you describe yourself
as a tactician an attacker you like that
attack um
let me let me let me um i like the
attack but
but
the pawn
i i would go with the pawn and you know
um kubotik actually has this really cute
um king and queen chocolates that you
can eat yeah but there's no pond like
that although they do have a
like baking stuff that you can make um
it has like a king so you can make a
chess piece exactly yeah right so if you
wanted a pond
if you actually wanted a pond that you
can eat i weren't hurt my niece and
nephew recently made me a birthday cake
where they had the chest set
yeah they put it on
unfortunately the chess set was only 32
in 64
pieces but i ate the 32 chocolate pieces
i i had some help um what's your take uh
christian uh or do you have another
position that that caught your tongue i
have a big position guys oh sophie
maurice sophie suzuki is winning again
no
she's winning again wow this lady is
going to go to six out of six in this
tournament and run away with the event
let's take a look and we were mentioning
this position after knight to g for
queen to e2 was the best move
nevertheless not easy to fight right
because take on c5 take on a6 and all
that craziness uh that was ensuing in
that variation with the king stuck on
the first rank we've seen that already
she was drawn that is ru yang yan to uh
the defense of the pawn on c5 with the
move queen to c2 the problem is that
after knight d3 which was on the board
queen to f2 knight takes d1 rook takes a
d1
by the way queen uh on c3 not queen to
f2 now i can just simply take on c5 with
the rook
you go to e3 you have to go to e3 either
otherwise i have discovery checks galore
in the position and you're just simply
going to lose and i see this position i
see the knight on a2 completely out of
the game
and i'm wondering why don't i just play
the move a5 stop you from going to b4 if
you give me another move for example if
you take on h3 after queen to c7 this
knight is almost stuck
on a2 you're in big big trouble at the
same time you cannot generate any sort
of initiative with your pieces your king
is still weak as white so
after a5 i'm thinking knight to c3 makes
a lot of sense try to activate the
knight try to find a good uh placement
for the knight the problem is that what
if i just simply go queen to e7 or rook
to b8 pretty much any of these moves you
take and then i go rook to c8
it feels like it's so much easier to
play with the black side right
the bishop spent some time taking this
pawn on h3 now facing this block of
pawns
especially spearheaded by this pawn on
e6
it's not getting activated anytime soon
at the same time black species are
waiting to invade white's position the
rook is going to come on the second rank
after remove the knight from c3
this is all sophie maurice suzuki in
this game and in this tournament
check that score line out after five i
mean
what else can be said about this perfect
score line this is
the tournament of sophie morris suzuki's
life right now wow
remark right well when we're talking
about a5 i just wanted to like whatever
if i right now what if i just want to
like torture my opponent
a little bit and don't take them
yeah
what if i just play like a5 so don't
just play knight before just it's not
like you can stop the c5 stuff well
can't i
defend the ball well i would happily
bring more attackers on it
oh you mean something like rook c7 and
just
wow that's uh
just to make sure that my it just hurts
you wanted it you you want to control
the night you want to control the knight
wow
um yeah that's a
intriguing idea i i was just
i was just so sure of rook c5 and queen
e3 no no it's okay you threw you you
threw me off completely
with uh such a suggestion um
one thing i would maybe be just a little
bit
weirded out about what dorsa is
this idea that two pawns yeah you're
giving me
two connected past pawns and
i kind of would feel like i i bailed and
if you don't take the pawn well then
i've got like night
and then it's a different ball game but
a5 uh just kind of controlling the night
something uh
i mean if you can do that do it slowly i
mean
uh sofia is really really really doing
well
and we're going to go to a commercial
break and as we do we wanted to tell you
that we asked the juniors
what were their goals
these are their answers
[Music]
what are the goals and ambitions that
you're bringing to this tournament
yo obviously i'm just looking to play
some good games i think
unlike prior years i'm not really
looking for a particular result i'm just
really trying to enjoy chess
for me this is you know one of the one
of the few tournaments i have planned
for the year so you know it's not
something that i'm putting myself
under too much pressure for and
obviously i'd like to like win some
games and play really well
but um more than just like a result i
always wanted to play good chefs and um
and just be satisfied with my uh my play
this tournament okay i mean i hope to
play a good chess obviously just get a
it's a pretty tight tournament anyone
can win i'll want to fight fight fight
for the top spots at least and okay
another personal goal is to get to 2500
i'm pretty close so well i'd be i'm
playing against like some of the best
juniors across the us i just want to
play my best and prove that like
i can do well and i just hope that i can
use this opportunity to the best of my
ability
most mainly just take it game by game
and not not i'm not thinking too much
about the end result but
more just move by move and
staying in good shape this is a very
strong tournament i've i'm i think i'm
second seeded in this tournament i hope
to win this tournament i'll do whatever
i can to do it well i mean i'm not
having i'm not really having any like
specific goal for the tournament i mean
not not really anything specific in
terms of results
um
not nothing crazy i'm just trying to
take it one game at a time
focus on what i can control and that's
about it just doing my best and being
happy with what i can do i'm gonna be
honest i don't really have much of a
goal except not to
lose too badly
i think that's like a fair standard to
hold myself to
be a good tournament and this will be
really embarrassing if i end up playing
really badly
but i'm just gonna say it now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of this round six
it's
sophie
she's caught over i know it's the sophie
show that's what it's turning into as um
as sophie
suzuki is five out of five
and she she did go for the pawn by the
way i mean
[Music]
rook takes c5 and here's our standings
and we see that she's
a clear point at first yeah and then
jennifer you and talia cervantes are
following her with four points each and
what's interesting is jennifer is
playing against rochelle rochelle's
saying hey wait a minute if i can
win i can join you jennifer jennifer's
saying look i've got to win so i can
keep pace with uh sophie
and in the juniors oh i was going to say
there's not the standings for them as
well
but to pick up where what we were
talking about is after the move queen c7
materially speaking white's not doing
that bad the problem is the coordination
of the pieces the minor pieces that is
to say two minor pieces for the rook
you're thinking should i take this pawn
or should i take this pawn which is kind
of like awkward i mean
near my king and the problem is the
central squares even though these pawns
are doubled they're covering a lot of
central squares it would be brilliant of
us to be able to play knight b4 and
knight d5 if that guy didn't exist
exactly but that guy does exist and
that's why we think um sophia is doing
very very well should she win this
obviously she jumps to six out of six
but this is not unusual
for uh girls championships junior
championships i've seen in the world
championships oftentimes you need a a
massive score like eight and a half out
of nine or eight out of nine
sometimes i've seen perfect scores even
nine out of nine what was your
best uh junior
championships youth champion well i was
i grew up and i was you know raised in
iran up until i was 17-18 and um so i
played some of the national events like
under 8 10 12 14. i think that was 8 10
12 14 right that's a lot of it and i
remember um i was under 10 and under 12.
i um i had two nine out of nines and i
was like
and i mean i had won the tournaments
like around the heads but i was just
like i really really want and there
wasn't any prize money it was a trophy
it was just like i want that perfect
score right it was quite how about you
um
no i i didn't have those um
eight out of eight kind of scores i i
won the world junior championship with
10 and a half out of 13.
uh which was a fine score but now i'm
seeing even much bigger scores than that
um
my best i i this was great this was
great this is my one of my favorite
stories
is on a completely crazy situation i was
on a plane
and i was going from what did you say
hamburg a plane okay i was going from
hamburg
to some place in england and i don't
even know remember the place
bristol maybe i'm not really too sure
anyway i looked oh my gosh my seated
mate that was sitting next to me was
anatoly carpenter oh nice
random universe right like bang bang
bang
and we got to talking and i said bobby
fischer had a 21-game win streak
he won 21 games in a row one was a
forfeit so 20 games in a row and i
thought well you know like talia that's
just incredible
what was your best
result
in terms of consecutive wins and he goes
i once had six zero
six zero i won six games in a row i said
wow you know linares uh 94 i believe
he said how about you and i said well
twice i've had
seven zero i won seven twice against
grand masters and he goes yeah yeah but
they weren't that good and i go actually
they were you were one of the victims of
the seven zero
[Laughter]
it was great that was like
a a beautiful moment christian um you've
played a lot of these junior youth
events you needed big scores right
no absolutely well in the romanian youth
events i think i scored quite a few
times 11 out of 11.
at the younger
age under 10 especially i think i had
maybe like two three years when i wanted
with the perfect score in the world you
know not worthy
but that was at the national level in
the world youth i did win under 16 with
an eight and a half out of 11. so
not a super major score right you know
they see nine maybe nine and a half
eight and a half did uh win uh during
those times in a general so right
nowadays i have a feeling that we're
seeing more and more of these type of
dominant scores especially when you have
a player that's just simply unstoppable
jennifer you had an almost perfect
tournament eight out of nine yeah well
ate a u.s championship yeah yeah she won
like 10 and a half 10 out of 11 she had
what was it was it eight out of nine or
was it
ten out of nine
eleven rounds i remember it was eleven
then it was maybe ten that was a monster
squad knew like i was looking like ah
she she won again she's beating
everybody so yeah
exactly uh
let's jump into the game of uh jennifer
and rachelle because we're kind of
seeing
those positions she did by the way
rochelle did
play
against the move
knight b3
the move c5 uh the most challenging
uh
and after bishop takes f6 g takes f6
whoa bishop takes rook takes
knight to d2
rook back pawn to e4 we're caught up
with the players but i have to say
i'm actually not that impressed
you see these pawns and you
it's scary it's scary like our king is
super exposed that was your initial
reaction right but then when you kind of
dig a little deeper this knight is not
going anywhere in fact after a move like
rook e8 and bishop c6 your knight is
actually kind of tethered
to this pawn on e4
and you're not going queen h5 and
checkmating me
the queen will not deliver checkmate by
herself
which is why way back here
i think it was incumbent upon jennifer
to play the move knight f3 in order to
go to 95. the current position i mean it
looks
visually like it's it's scary but once
you look at rookie eight and say okay
go ahead and checkmate me
[Laughter]
[Music]
right if our rook was on f1 by the way
one move that i might find attractive
would be something like
this again if my rook was on f1 and i
could put my pawn on f5
my knight on e4 would suddenly be a
a thor a god of wonder but on d2 it
looks pretty well normal uh jump right
in uh christian uh jennifer
missed her
mr target to give you an assessment of
the position actually not only that she
missed her target but right now she's
worse yes much worse after rook to e8 uh
as you pointed out rook to e8 just put
pressure on the pawn on e4 to not allow
this knight to get back into the game
right of course imagine a knight landing
on d5 that would be an ideal scenario
yeah for white you're not getting there
any time soon i'm going to put a lot of
pressure on this pawn on e4 and
unfortunately this knight is stuck to
the defense of the pawn on e4 rook to e8
bishop to c6 is one of the moves you can
even reinforce your attack with the move
queen to d6 not only that but the queen
on d6 is ready to jump to d4 and put a
lot more pressure on the pawn on e4 at
the same time it has some defensive
tasks and that is defending this pawn on
f6 for example
uh after a bishop to f c6 which makes a
lot of sense queen to g4 king to f8 and
queen to h4 could potentially become a
little bit problematic nevertheless it
does seem like even this
works quite nicely for a black after the
move queen to d6 or even queen to d8
nevertheless you can prepare this whole
sequence by defending first in
anticipation of this maneuver the pawn
on f6 with the move queen to d6 it just
feels like everything is flowing in
black's direction
not only the position but also the time
right now i see rochelle with 26 minutes
jennifer with only 16 minutes and a lot
of moves to make 16 moves still to go in
the position and if we go uh back of
couple of moves
at this point move 21 only three moves
ago jennifer was up by six minutes 35
minutes against 29 minutes but she spent
a lot of time on this decision 20
minutes on a bishop takes e4 which was
indeed a very uh consequential decision
knight to d to rook to e7 e4
rook to a rook 88 is on the board and
rochelle wu is taking over the
initiative in this game
all right well thank you for that i just
uh checking and always checking in on
our tournament leaders
can we sorry
a quick look at talia's game so that we
can wrap up the um the
ladies section
one more yeah
almost there nice okay actually we're
right there never mind right
yeah and what's your
what what are you thinking
i mean since i picked talia's person to
win
okay so
the last move i think was
a5 until you're sitting there going ah i
want to chase your knight back into
purgatory
uh get out of here bishop a6 now that is
inviting
you know i
i have this like sixth sense where pawns
are concerned that isn't yes my spidey
senses says uh what about the move
bishop g4 give me your queen
if you play the move f2 f3 to defend
your queen oh a lot of things then i can
pick up this pawn
i agree i am losing an exchange but
that's one pawn
because it's jack
and that looks like a second pawn so
that's something that would
i immediately attract my attention now
if i could get you to move your queen
well then i'm really happy because i can
trade and rescue my rook
and at the end of the day
nobody is saving the pawn on h5 so i
would think bishop g4
is very doable i think too i would be
reluctant
to play rook c7 because oops yeah
now because now you have to start
trading pieces
and the trades are going to be
beneficial for white um
even with the fact that this pawn is on
h5
sorry i was just gonna say in the game
talia just played drake e8 after bishop
a6
oh well
then the move a bishop a
six by alice is definitely worthwhile
because rook c1
ah probably queen b2 maybe queen b2
keeps uh the initiative going
hmm bishop geforce is still incoming so
i'm still
comfortable with black's position i
wouldn't say you know winning but i feel
like it's just black is maybe has an
edge
if i can eat the h5 pawn now we can
start talking uh about it
uh rook well jeez if i have to play rook
c1 queen
c2 rook c2 bishop takes b3 i'm not a big
fan of giving up this pawn but
sometimes you've got to do what you got
to do is this
i mean okay i'm i'm starting to
get scared and looking for a way of
bailing out
this pawn on h5 is not very good she's
reaching for a bishop she's not reaching
for a rook how the camera is trying to
zoom in
bishop to b5
okay let's see what alice has in mind
she's just played bishop asic she chased
the rook away yes
and then came bishop rook a8 bishop b5
the first thing i'm thinking is i just
want to go a4 i just want to kick your
knight
which is why she played
a5 in the first place you can't really
stop my bishop g4 so i just want to kick
the knight away make sure i'm
interfering with rook c1
and
yeah then maybe i'll just bring bishop
to g4 if need be
if that pawn proves worthy
how could it not right why could it not
bishop the g bishop to e2
okay this still work it's not uh
it's not like
done and dusted yes
now my rook on a8 also kind of feels
like it has a purpose and so uh even if
not bishop's g4 even if we decide to
just kind of lets that pawn on h5 be
worried i i do like a4 in that case if
you know after k8 bishop b5 a4 whoops
yep sorry oh
you're wishing for bishop to be fourth
i'm sorry i i really i i
because it's the first move i put in the
position the the system thinks that uh
that was the move that was played bishop
b5 a4 yep yep if
and then the nightmares maybe even the
afro can just join the party rook c8 so
yeah now the a2 pawn is weak so your a1
rook is kind of preoccupied your knight
on d2 is kind of looking funny queen on
d1 is the same winner d1 is just stuck
by the h i i really like this as black
agreed agreed uh you just have to
you just have to look at the captures to
make sure that it's all good i think
bishop g4 is a great answer
once again to any captures my queen
feels a little overwhelmed
of course of course you can i i'm trying
to bail out of what i think what does
she do
oh she brought the rock
huh i mean still logical but
a4 just felt so natural because you just
you had just played a5
right so
i'm not sure what i think alice has
really
gone wrong like
wrong wrong
uh first of all
i was trying to come up with a good
alice in wonderland pun but i failed no
it's not there uh first of all um
compare the knights first for a second
so this knight
on
f6 has a target
but it also has some nice squares that
it can jump to spicy when you play
knight b3 where's your knight going in
terms of going forward
it's not going anywhere c5 c1 knight d3
knight
it's all
so
wrong
now
if white's pawns were on f3
and e4 the knight would be misplaced it
would be um
it would be contained so the move knight
b3 is literally a step in the wrong
direction because there's no further
step
also
the bishop on e2
we're running into bishop g4 and certain
variations i mean it would really have
behooved
um
alice to play a move like for example a4
an a5 maybe bishop f3 so she could jump
her knight to e4 so in in a sense what
i'm saying is she misplaced her pieces
knight there she misplaced her bishop
oh again that that keeps going
rook a8 yeah uh bishop to b5
and talia's pieces are again i prefer
your a5 a4 move but
this bishop looks misplaced there was a
reason i was their captain yeah
you were there captain uh slow women's
team okay okay let's jump over to uh
christian for uh news i want to hear
about this captaincy just a second guys
the games are hitting up in all three
sections but i was uh taking a look at
what's happening in the junior section
and it seems like david brodsky
might be headed towards his first
victory and against a wander yank the
rating favorite in this event and we
were mentioning this position yesterday
you did not believe no that black has
enough compensation and he did not
because he missed a bit he played this
move queen to d7 we were discussing this
position you're still far away from
involving this rook into play so what
black has to do is immediately go bishop
to g6 followed by knight to f5 that was
the only way to maintain equality
maintain the balance and have the
initiative play for you after that
instead of that he missed a bit with his
move queen to d7 allowed bishop to h5 a
very clever move not only that i'm
taking away the g6 square from the
bishop but also i'm getting ready to
develop my knight knight to e2 knight to
f4 and this is exactly what he did
bishop to f7 knight to f3 knight to f5
finally uh the knight landed on a5 but
it's one move too late bishop to h6 take
on h6 knight to e2
queen to d7 queen to e1 and once again i
am upon up i am a pawn up and i do have
a lot of pressure on your beautiful
knight on e4 and it doesn't seem like
you have enough compensation for the
lost material right now as black how do
you develop your advantage how do you
develop your initiative i know what i'm
going to do as white i'm going to go
queen to e2 and then rook to f1 and ask
you
what are you going to do in the meantime
because i have a beautiful night ready
to jump to f7 if your knight from h6
moves away as well you want to take on
g3 and i really like this move rook to
f3 because it nicely protects everything
the complex of pieces around white's
king rook to f3 cements the knight on g3
you will never be able to take it on g3
because after route to g3 i'm just
invading uh next to your king i really
like what david is doing in this one
let's take a look at what's happening in
the justin wang versus the leader of our
event
christopher woo and we have this
position it has simplified quite a lot
but
one thing that has stayed the same
there's still an extra pawn for black
right so how do we assess the
disposition i understand the material is
very simplified
with some good moves some very precise
moves maybe white has a decent chance of
finding equality but how easy it is and
i do believe that this move f4 was quite
a good move a very precise move
if you don't do that i am going to be
able to take advantage of that
potentially rook to a1 followed by rook
to a2 and pin the pawn on f2 you cannot
allow that that's why he played move f4
rook to a1 king to g2 rook way to
you have to drop back to g1 for example
if you go to h3 after knight to f2 your
king might get in trouble you don't want
to see that on the board so
king to g1 i understand your cut you
don't have a lot of flexibility with
your king but what you can do is try to
get this knight to g5 or to e5 and put
some pressure of your own
on a black spawns on the king side at
the same time once you remove the knight
from d4 this pawn is going to go down
the board i have to say i'm looking at
the position i know christopher is a
grinder he knows how to grind this type
of minimal advantages
i also look at the time only nine
minutes left for adjusting wang
definitely a lot of pressure for the
young player with the white pieces
christopher might be headed towards
another victory in this one
remarkable uh
in the game between andrew hong and
carissa yeah
whenever i'm playing
or one of the
people who are doing badly in the
tournament
this is the time for me where i get
nervous
it's really weird it's sort of like
everybody's beating up on this poor
person right my turn
to beat up
on this poor person and it's sort of
like
this is a game i really have to win
because she because carissa is giving
away like father christmas the points
so i when i'm playing somebody in the
cellar i really don't want to give them
chances
let's take a look at what happened this
is the benoni
position that we left it we didn't like
carissa's position we thought she's
losing d6 and the move bishop to g3 was
an issue but bishop takes d6
a3
and look what happened
you played the move g4 already well okay
in a benoni you know uh
look at this
you're gonna win it apiece you're you're
earning it yeah carissa said you know
what
you can win my rook
who cares take the rook
so he took the rook all right b5
and the position just blowed up
like
you're what i'm thinking in porter expo
both
both i want to take this bishop and
you're king at the end of the day you've
kind of
exposed your king to all kinds of things
and
when you're in andrew's position it's
sort of like
gosh i'm playing the tail ender
and
uh oh i'm getting scared because i can
see
that if i lose a bishop there's going to
be compensation right
like this is going to be like one of
those positions where you just know
that things are gonna get real messy
right exactly they're gonna get really
messy and knight takes e2 and queen g5
check i mean if you do something like
this this is just going to be game over
on the spot
so uh what is the times of the players
dorsa
oh my god career system still have less
than 10 minutes she's been in time
trouble almost every game
and at this point andrew seems to have
17 minutes on camera okay
nice time match for andrew yeah i did
want to mention though after pawn to b5
yes remember that story i told you i had
that one student that i accidentally
made cry yes oh
good for you
yeah making turning them into champions
you know telling the kid that you know
there's always a butt you put you know
you make this move you have there's pros
there's cons and then he was like but
that's so weird i don't want to think of
chess like that i was a kid that's just
life and then he just started crying
but guys
alarming in that position about
carissa's time expenditure is that they
also have like 20 moves to go right
that's what i was saying 21 in a wild
banoni with well you just sacrificed a
rook right that means there's increments
there is increments i understand that
yes but my point is pawn to b5 yes it's
actually c4 but it's it's the like the
c5 pawn is still you know there's that
butt with the c5 pawn can i just eat the
c5
it's not so easy i'll take on e2 with a
check okay
you'll take kind of now unfortunately
queen the desirable queen g5 check is
not mate okay because you've got queen
g4 but i do take your knight
i feel like i have to move the queen
exactly but then i'm kind of winning
back the the whole rook that i just
sacrificed by uh ponte in other words
yes you can return the rook
and by the way i don't think theresa is
going to go for that really what do you
think she's c5 take on c5 i think she's
going to go for queen h4 knowing karissa
huh i think she's gonna try to go for
the checkmate
and check me
wow
just uh say okay you're a full rook up
but i might as well try to check with
you scary stuff scary stuff scary stuff
and now white has to go king h2 which
once again a very scary move queen to e4
the position is completely wild queen to
e4 i see the checkmate that you're
trying to engineer
holy smokes and that's the question how
do you uh attribute your resources along
the way right because you only have
eight minutes left on the clock are you
going to spend
four minutes to try to calculate this
type of variation where are you going to
go
knight takes e2 19 moves that's a lot
uh so what i'm saying is carissa's
swinging for the fences yes and you
don't want to go down against the tail
ender so that you start you know feeling
nervous there was only one game in my
entire career that would i was ever
nervous about from the start i've had
many times black pieces against gary
kasparov and anatoly karpov it was
against comrade shirazi oh kamran
shirazi started the u.s championship
like 0-6
and it was my turn i have to win i mean
i absolutely keep pace with the players
i have to win against comrade and
he was a very very dangerous opponent i
mean he could beat anybody on any given
day this was not his tournament
i ended up winning but it wasn't until
like
you know three hours into the game when
i knew i was going to win the game
it's scary and queen h4 would
[Laughter]
terrify me as well so yeah b b5 uh jump
right in uh christian
what
should andrew play
to tame the position down there's no
taming the position okay
you're not gaming that position you you
are forced to calculate right now so
bishop takes e5 is actually the best
move in the position pick up the pawn
but more importantly destabilize the
knight on d4 i think that's quite
important and after queen to h4 this is
the line that we were discussing king to
h2
queen to uh e4 and now after f3 it does
seem like you're forced to go queen
takes e2 once you exchange the queens
i'm going to be happy right right
because of i was just trying to avoid
that yeah that's the thing you you just
simply it doesn't seem like you have
enough time to avoid it now you can also
take on nito instead of queen to h okay
can i go bishop e oh sorry
i still have bishop knight on c4 i know
it's attacked
by two pieces it feels like it's already
gone off the board right but it's not
it's still there so gotcha sorry you
were about to say after bishop c5 queen
h
maybe just king h2 maybe just the normal
knight takes e2 instead of queen to h4
and how do we assess that position is
the question right so exactly two you
take on c4 next and that would go queen
to e4 or queen to f3 let's say right
right how do we assess this position
well it's an extra pawn for white for
sure right
extra pawn after bishop takes f1 yes
do we take with the rook or with the
king i was thinking about maybe i should
have i should have started maybe with
queen g5 check but that's okay then
a8 is
not protected so that's another oh
excuse me you're right that's another
temple right so maybe i can go king h1
hide my king like that that is true no
no no no
uh it's an extra pawn for white is it
terrible i don't know uh
we're playing for two results it seems
like
i
right is it i think so yeah cause b2 is
hanging chris but maybe i can take with
the rook just because i want to prepare
uh b4 this is the dream position for me
i want to play b4 i want to stabilize
the bishop on c5
and get the king on c1 and just say that
i have enough and by the way none of
this will happen because we just saw a
move andrew played bishop g3 he got
scared of queen h4 of queen h4 and he
said no no i i'm trying to
control
temper the position but without the pawn
on c5 that night will live forever on d4
right now yeah and that's a powerful
night that's a beautiful night
i'm starting to warm up to karissa's
position thank you that well that's
where it gets scary right again you're
playing the tail ender
nobody wants to lose to the tail ender
but in this particular position
carissa's got a really dangerous
initiative i'll just leave it there and
say i don't doubt that black pardon me
white has defensive resources
but having the initiative with less time
and by the way i just checked with the
engine bishop to g3 threw away the whole
advantage really in one move just one
move not only that but if you don't play
the best moves right now you might be
worse as white
the knight on d4 is such a powerful
piece not only that but you have to
contend with ideas of bishop to c6
followed by queen to d5 or maybe bishop
to b7 followed by queen to d it's so
difficult and don't forget this bishop
need to kind of have to stay here you
can take a pawn on c4 but then you have
to return to e2 because knight f3 is
coming on the board so
there's so many things that you have to
worry about
in this position as white from a
practical perspective with the clock
ticking down and only
12 minutes for andrew or maybe less than
that right now uh well unfortunately
with 20 moves to go like 90 moves to go
this is starting to become a very
difficult task exactly i wanted to also
just
point out boldly point out the obvious
carissa's knight on d4 is defended by
the pawn on c5
which is also defended by the bishop on
g7
and
we're lauding it we're saying it's
fantastic it creates all of these
threats remember the game of jennifer uh
you for just a moment
where she could have played
against rochelle
she could have played right back here
after bishop might have 395 ideas yeah
knight oh pardon me rook d1 bishop d7
knight f3 and again if we make just one
move for
knight e5 you see the similarity
the bishop on b2
protects the knight on e5 the pawn
protects the knight and the knight on e5
is awesome by the way now that we're
here let me just check in on
sophie she didn't play your a5
pawn four
no strange move right that's a
very very peculiar move i thought that
i thought our only discussion was bishop
h3
bishop a6 or knight b4
a4
and sophie said well wait a minute this
knight is a little stuck how are you
ever getting your knight rook b8
um
sophie's playing great she's just
playing great chess guys but i want to
take the camera sure right now to
jennifer's position and let's take a
look and see
what her response will be because she
only has one move and if she takes
she's losing there is only one way so
let's take a look at the camera of
jennifer you right now
let's see if she's going to find it
you have to have an image of like 12
people in production right running down
the street with cameras behind them
entering the playing hall full of sweat
not only the fact that she only has one
move to survive but she only has four
minutes to make 45 seconds
to go
okay i'm assuming it's g4 no
it's not no g g4 is losing
e5 is the only move and sacrifice a
queen after bishop to g4 with the move
knight to e4 yes exactly finally the
knight
lands
on the great square f6 e5 is the
critical move if she finds that she has
good chances of survival if she doesn't
she's busted ouch and just for
um
our panel here in studio uh g4
bishop takes g4 rook g1
h5 i'm assuming or f5 i was i was trying
to
break the blockade on the g-file
didn't work
christian no i don't think it does so
let's uh
take a look how do we do things here
i i love your solution first of all what
if i just go king h8
oh i was attacking your queen and you
don't even move your queen
right oh well that ruins it all right
he's a party pooper he didn't move his
queen i was going to go knight to e3
that's a really good f8
yeah but i love your solution you know
the moment you mentioned it you it
becomes a very
visual e5
uh
guys
um
just to continue the position there's
queen takes d1 let it keep six i kinda
feel like i wanna do it automatically
you're right i guess i i moved my king
now you can
take my queen and take my rook i think
that's the
way you go
but that queen takes d1 i mean you got
to see some really nice tactics oh we're
about to see some really nice tactics if
she finds the movie that's the timing
one second at a time 2 minutes and 47
seconds guys
for who what
put that impartial
two minutes and 30 seconds against 17
minutes for rochelle
e5 guys this is it this is this is a
critical moment if not e5 then
right
because sophie is running away with it
right well i feel like sophie's already
bye-bye she's she's 11. next please wow
6-0 if she goes 6-0 but uh the problem
is i think jennifer has
these false leads like you might be
tempted to think you could play f5 and
the bishop's trapped
until you see bishop takes f5 yes
so you have to calculate that and then
say
oh no she played f5 yes sir
wait a minute
i jinxed it right what just happened
guys but what about bishop takes that
fight instantly excuse me what is that
there's no other choice but that's a
great move bishop takes f5 but that just
finishes the game yeah yeah she missed
bishop takes f5 but no she did there's
nothing there is absolutely nothing
right now
that's a blunder alert i'm afraid uh
bishop f5 she just forgot we're in the
third fourth hour or third hour of the
year we are entering blender well so
time trouble by the way jennifer has
been getting into time trouble
very much
like
chris
carissa who's been getting into time
trouble but jennifer has been playing
very well in time trouble the move f5
but five i mean the first thing you want
to think about is what if take i mean
there is no other alternative yes this
is the puzzle because if they don't take
the bishop is just gone she's lost
exactly exactly
maybe she's seeing ghosts there's no way
she missed bishop takes a fight but what
was her thinking so could she be
thinking
i don't know
i i mean i don't know what she was
calculating guys i i'm really puzzled by
this decision f5 this chance should grab
the wrong pawn to play right
uh
and she's about she's below that and
after
her opponent's reaction bishop takes f5
she didn't
bring bring her move instantly i think
she just completely
missed bishop f5 she she was looking at
something else
and to draw as our first results our
first result
uh a lot of the games in all of the
rounds
we we've been seeing hours and hours of
play before the first result i remember
in the candidates like we had a result
within eight minutes
it was like what and all of these uh
rounds have been really hard fought
jennifer just played the move queen
but now
it drops back to g6 beautiful protection
around the king
there is nothing here for white well
except a lot of uh negative pawns
exactly yes yes
um
a a big blunder by one of our
pre-tournament favorites jennifer
and here with this head-to-head result
uh larry christensen moves to four
beautiful vladimir kopian three and a
half as
larry keeps his slim lead two players
i believe it's max delugey and dimitri
garvich might still be able to catch him
uh with wins of course oh yes yes you're
right about this yes with wins uh just
checking in on sophia um
the last move by rue yang
uh was
you know to give her knight
uh against rook to b2 give her a knight
the square c3 but the knight is not
any great shakes once it gets to c3 it's
not going anywhere
would you prefer this position
to play for a win or would you prefer
the the rochelle boos position to play
for a win i mean like would you prefer
to be black in this position on playful
oh rochelle's position is so much
cleaner i mean she's got two extra pawns
and
all beautiful harmony and coordination
and weak pawns on e4 uh very very nice
let me just check in on talia's game for
a second tell ya okay i think time first
thing looking good talia is looking good
guys right talia is looking really good
well first of all knight to e4 was
played right so what if i just simply go
bishop b3 now correct and i force the
trade of the queens which were taken
into the almost winning
no no no no no the bishop on d3
yeah but there's a there's a rook on a8
oh
yes sir tricky dog
all right but what if i go g4 first oh
g for first yes queen
that's okay now i think ah
bishop back to e6 and now
finally
yeah i ran out of cheapos
bishop b3 you were about to say i was
going to be forced to trade queens with
but that's not nice
this is not a nice and you have to also
take back with a bishop buddy question
yes instead of trading queens can i just
eat the a3 pawn
probably i love uh the superiority of
black's pieces i mean again i mean
queen b2 she's going for it guys
what if she's hovering over the bishop
it seems like
i think she should see the hand
i see this in scholastic i think she's
going to go for it
i warn players don't get in the habit of
doing what talia is doing
don't do this it's really really really
bad
uh yeah instead
it's on the board
be sure about your move when you're
certain that you're going to play bishop
b3 grab the bishop do it immediately
if you hover opponents will understand
what you're trying to do bingo
[Laughter]
why give them information about what
you're going to play
especially in the surprise yeah
surprisingly but like this one i mean
bishop b3 was kind of coming we can't
really stop it but that'd be bad bad bad
habits
uh stop them
early and again this hovering and the
worst is to make your move
oh uncomfortable and then keep your pawn
keep your finger
i see that in scholastics too and i say
don't how about the i've had like really
tricky upon us so like what about like
you know like if you want to play bishop
b3 like first go like hover around the
other rook for a minute yeah and just to
make your friends go what is she going
to blender
move the actual
i know
okay talia's looking really good in this
one uh where do you want us to go
christian how about the carissa game
well i mean i really feel like we should
stay with the ladies game especially our
leader sophie mori suzuki for the moment
and maybe we can pan the camera on her
as well see what her reaction is because
right now she's getting close to just
putting the finishing touches on her
opponent rook to situ is on the board
knight to c3 and look at that focused
young lady right now what if you just
simply go rook to b3
keep keep the pressure going attack the
knight right
rook to d rook to b3 seems like a very
compelling decision and move right now
and
looking at the position the more pieces
we trade and the more we're getting
close to an end game where i can pick up
that a pawn and create a past pawn on
the far away a
file well the closer we get to that the
more
closer i get to a winning position a
completely devastating position
absolutely the move rook b three looks
very very compelling
um normally speaking you'd love to
double the rooks on the seventh rank as
well but that will only come and we have
just been told
that right now there is somebody in the
chat that says that if sophie goes 9-0
he will be donating one hundred dollars
to the sales
by the way
let's look at some great results
uh of these kinds of winning starts
uh six and a half out of seven uh was
vessel and topolof way back
in what was then not
the candidate's tournament that was the
world championship he became the feed a
world champion by virtue of a six and a
half out of seven starts in 2005 in san
luis argentina he won the event what
else wow
we'll never forget this one we were here
for that wow we witnessed it in real
time fabi seven out of seven i can't
believe he didn't go eight out of eight
by the way because he was winning
against magnus i believe in that eighth
game
jennifer
yep straight what you said she won eight
in a row it's like depressing
right man yeah right uh to any 19 and
yeah
five and a half out of seven
really really nice i mean fabi through
the first half was giving him chase
flabby i think was five out of seven he
was he was only a half a point behind
and normally thinking fabi might have
felt like i'm in first place
no you were in clear second fabi
and here's sophie five out of five
well she's going for a six out of six
yeah right now i mean did she play rook
b3 by the way chris she has not no she's
still thinking she's by the way
is not the only move no of course not uh
another way to exchange the rooks is to
go rook to d8 that's the
easier way the simpler way ah
so big moment right now still only four
minutes by the way for rueyang and uh
eight moves seven moves to go
i have to ask who is the youngest
participants at like in the in the girls
event is
fourteen or fifteen i think mishra is
thirteen
alice lee is
alice is twelve thirteen i think she's
thirteen also
so it's mishra and alice lee you're
right wonderful
well those were the two that came
immediately tomorrow yeah i remember
alice lee was one of the i think the
youngest participant in the american
club so i assumed that she would be the
angus here but i wasn't so sure about
that alice is phenomenal i mean at 12
years old uh
having her own video channel
it's just like
it's just
alice's pawn palace on
you chesskids.com i mean it's just it's
just marvelous to me and i need
inspiring
you know children all over the world to
take up chess i just she's got
total respect for me it's like well done
alice i like rook d8 something about
rook b3
you know that's
you know that's not the lazy lazy
player's move because then you start
thinking about knight b5 and d5 right
yeah sophie's
rook d8 is a lot simpler you don't have
any tactics to worry about id5 knight b5
discovered attacks against the rook on
b3 rook v8 looks like a very very
powerful move i sorry i i'm more
involved i'm more interested in what's
going on in the andrew
uh han karissa yep game because
that's exciting and this is really
really good stuff going on please
impress you with that nice p5 idea oh i
just admire people who can sacrifice
rooks like it's no no big deal
queen d7 she she's eyeballing an
opportunity and as uh christian was
mentioning the bishop
well you got to be worried there's a
knight f3 check so in other words bishop
g4 might just be met by queen takes g4
and that will uh hurt your feelings king
h2 rookie 8 bishop d1
king h7
wow where did she come up with that i
thought that whole idea of you know
getting your queen on this diagonal was
attractive maybe queen f5
uh king h7 okay
we're caught up to the players how many
moves what's the times dorset um well
both players have around four minutes uh
andrew has three minutes and a half
kyrisa has four minutes and 20 seconds
and they have
13 more moves to go but
there's increments i'm not terribly
worried about their time but
this is such a nice game even if they
had like an hour and a half this would
still
get go whoa
wait i feel like the last few moves
andrew is
andrew's doing well he's improved
his situation have i got that right uh
uh christian that uh
well yes yes yes i i i think you're
right yes i think you're right about
that i can go rook to g1 obviously i
have to defend against checkmate there's
not a lot of ways to do that but a
couple of games that i think should be
finishing very very soon are actually
the one between pedro espinosa versus a
brand new number behind you
forget about the number it's only one
minute and 20 seconds for pedro right
now to make his next move and he doesn't
have any next move because you have to
take on d6 i take back and now the
bishop ran out of squares you're going
to have to sacrifice it and then this is
just a piece of
absolutely no compensation we expect the
resignation in this one okay another one
in which we expect a resignation is the
game between
david brodsky and a wonder and this
position after router g7 actually queen
to f6 was such a nice touch if you would
have found this if you take now i
transfer the knight to h6
by force and now i go queen to f8 rook
to g8 knight to f7 you're actually
losing the queen by force and by the way
brandon jacobson has won his description
did resigned he had absolutely nothing
to do at that point so
big moment in this one he did not uh
play queen f6 he played queen to g3
queen to h5 but this is completely
winning as well
one we expect once again reinforcing uh
terrible threats on the f file you have
to defend against that unfortunately my
queen is getting in queen h4 my rook is
getting in
look at the domination knight on e5 and
the bishop on e4 we expect a resignation
to come shortly in this game between
david brotzky and a wonder and take it
all back guys to the carissa game
because that
oh my goodness f3 another rook to g1 and
this gives karissa a winning advantage
after knight to f5 that tables have
turned guys
not a surprise because this was a
double-edged position very easy to make
mistakes with an exposed king let's see
what carissa whether she finds this move
knight to f5 and turns the tables on her
opponent right now i bet she will and
it is on the board guys beautifully done
i i bet she wouldn't i'll tell you
exactly why please because
white had played queen f4 with the idea
of maybe playing queen h4 check nice so
not only do you block your opponent's
threat
you open up the rook
you open up the bishop like give me the
rook but you also
bishop
nice i did so good at knight f5 it just
like it's a triple
threat it's ding ding ding ding you
you you you stop your opponent from
playing queen h4 bishop e5 bishop takes
e3 that's a gorgeous move uh carissa
and how big is it did you say winning
winning advantage decisive advantage
right now and decisive advantage if
white plays well like if white plays the
move queen to c1
which is not an easy move yeah that's
finding that move that doesn't come
immediately to mine where am i going
with my queen
i don't know
queen to c1 well if you take on c4 and
to my eyes that looks like the more
natural move
yes queen takes c4 exactly
no i just simply go queen to d2 check
check
i'm invading can i just and he did he
did he took on c4 yeah
that's a much more natural approach but
queen d2 check just finishes the game
you have to play bishop f2 let's just
take a look queen d2 jack yes you can't
move the king because the bishop on g3
is hanging yes so you have to drop back
and you can't move the rook because the
bishop on d1 is and now we see the
beautiful geometry in the position
bishop to f2
queen to d6 check
i wasn't looking that direction i was
looking at the bishop
backward moves guys whenever you're on
the attacker one of the most some of the
most difficult moves to see and not only
that you're giving a check but also
you're supporting bishop to a6
oh
that is the geometry in the position
that i was talking about
thank you
i have to ask can i just eat the rook
instead of this check just c3 rook is
kind of
that's a young thinking it's it's not
enough then like
not enough to go fast
he's done it by the way bishop f2 again
what are the times dorset um charissa
has three minutes counting and andrew
has two minutes 47. so they're both
in time trouble pressure yeah time
trouble uh that move bishop a6 that is
just such a nasty move queen this is e6
check
because the first thing you want to do
is involve all your bits right so bishop
e5 check kind of
like
makes an impression
bishop d4 makes an impression
uh there's a couple of ways of going
wrong but
oh no
queen f7 shaq well but bishop takes oh
oh yeah i was thinking that i wanted to
take this bishop but queen f7
uh hurts my feelings um she did
something she did not play it she played
bishop e5 she played bishop e5 it's so
natural to want to involve
everybody that
queen d6 was difficult
bishop takes c3 if queen takes c3 there
was a cute knight e3 because if you take
my queen knight takes f1 and
gotcha
yeah sweet
i'm happy with this bishop e5 turns the
tables one more time
again right now
equal
suddenly
oh boy
hold on let me just refresh my board i i
beg your pardon by the way again two
results one in the seniors a draw with
our tournament leader
and uh brandon has won
and guess what brandon's with
christian
well
uh brandon welcome back to the show
congratulations a big victory with the
black pieces how did you leave this game
well i mean going to the game i figured
i'm not i'm already not in the
contention for anything at this point so
i just kind of wanted just to have fun
with it
and it's my opening choice um
and just see where it goes i honestly
didn't really think too much about the
game i'm just trying to enjoy it at this
point but i feel it felt like after
knight to d6 the position was actually
simplifying were you
how happy were you to see that i guess
yeah so this queen state was definitely
a bit too ambitious i mean i think i i
overestimated my position
um i think instead of queen c i should
just go rick's theater and play this
thing game and of course black should be
better with the two bishops um and
i think
after queen ca knight b5 and all these
complications i mean
i think if um
yeah so instead of quincy i think rick's
ch is a lot more logical um
rook to c8 right yes so queen takes d6
queen takes c6 take everything
i guess white castles in the end
um
but you are not interested in getting
this yeah i mean of course black is
better with two bishops but it's pretty
simplified i was looking for something
better i mean it felt like i should have
something more than this honestly i mean
it felt like all my his he's still not
castly i should have something but i
just totally missed that after um and by
the way just to interrupt you for a
second david brosky did win his game
against a wonder liang let's continue
results are coming in huh yeah fast and
furious yeah so i mean with all these
lines i missed afternoon i'd take i
wanted to go queen let's say c7 or e6
doesn't really make a difference looks
like queen c7
uh bishop takes f3 rook d8
um queen b4
and here i thought like from a few
minutes back i thought i had a knight c6
here
uh knight where's c6 c6 okay bishop
takes c6 queen takes e6 castle and i
thought a5 was winning a piece for me
from before we didn't take six yeah
i mean
yeah
easy to miss from afar yes
and it turns out yeah he just
consolidates everything after queen b4
so i can't really go for this
um so i'm kind of forced to simplify
everything with knight e4 75 but you
still found this uh very tricky idea to
uh leave the pawn on c4 actually
not that one yeah i consider this but he
said i mean
like black should have enough
compensation for a draw here but i don't
think
more than that yeah precisely yes um
but yeah in the end game i think it was
still a bit tricky for him like after
knight b3 i mean
yeah so i really like this idea of you
leaving the pawn on c4 and going knight
to b3 right i mean after knight b3 i
think rook b1 is just too passive he has
to castle here
instead of b1 bishop takes b2 and let's
say a4 just keep the pawn
i know it's pretty imbalanced here it's
probably around equal maybe something
like king g7 but i figured it's at least
something to play for like he has some
weaknesses to worry about
like the knight on b3 actually does a
very good job of like cutting covering
bishop d4 if everyone want to go like
bishop a3 bishop c5 for example
um so even though knights look kind of
awkward they cover a lot of squares and
then c4 is always a week too so
that'll have decent chances here at
least even if it's maybe around equal um
but yeah i think after this it sort of
started to go wrong for a while
especially after c5 i think c5 is
i mean practically seems close to losing
i think
instead of c5 i guess he probably just
has to castle
and i take c4 and then like take a take
on c4 and go with d1 and try to try to
hold this once again it was about
finishing development and getting all
your pieces active for white right to
keep the balance and after that it did
go
a stray for uh black for white yeah i
mean maybe his one last chance was after
rook bd8
yeah maybe he has to try to like take
and go let's say
yeah i guess taking camp one for example
bishop d4 or knight e4 and try to draw
one of these end games um which is maybe
some drawing chances after and then like
or takes p2 take take and like bring the
king in and then
maybe there are some holding chances but
yeah the way the game went i think it
was just
yeah it's pretty much over brandon uh
big victory for you still three games to
go how would you assess your chances to
maybe catch up with the leaders i mean
not very good at this point it seems
like christopher's winning this game as
well he's playing really well um so i'm
not really thinking about that but just
trying to take it one game at a time
especially given the quality of my games
thus far i'm definitely not happy with
it so just trying to hopefully play some
better chess in the last three rounds
still three rounds to go keep on
fighting and we'll see you in the next
rounds
uh well done uh brandon and we've got
more results uh
dorsey oh well david broadski did a win
against
a wandering liang and well it puts both
of them at two and a half points
wait i think that please hear me but i
think david won the last two games
i think he beat karissa before the rest
day and now one uh wonder
david brosky no definitely not no no no
david broski drew against uh karissa in
the first round if i'm not mistaken or
the second round the second round who am
i thinking about then my opponent check
it
oh
my apologies right it didn't but it
didn't sound right
let's get back to that chris again yes
yes let's do it quick because a lot of
things are changing
every single day i just wanted to say
that sophie is definitely winning uh
rue yang isn't
is destroying her opponent exactly uh
unfortunately for carissa so is andrew
hong right now is looking really good
after rook to e1 uh oh andrew hung has
turned the table secured the position of
the king and after rook to e1 let's keep
an eye on the camera because
we need to stay with the players right
now
he has to play in five minutes
carissa just played the move bishop
bishop b seven to season 8 was the last
what is she doing trying to set up some
discovery attacks
though
i don't like this 10 seconds
rookie one the best movie in the
position
crushing advantage for andrew
okay crushing
what is crushing plus means
yes crushing advantage
there's no more moves it seems like for
a black what happened so
what happened to chris's advantage she
blew it
it's changed hands with every single
move it's gone with the win
but was there a specific move that
should just happen a number of them the
most the worst one was bishop e5
right here she was winning
with queen the sixth between c6
resource right and bishop a6 hitting the
rook you mentioned
bishop takes c3 which was also a very
nice one queen takes c3 knight e3
with a
winning little four coming exactly
theresa down to her last with the
winning material 30 seconds guys but in
fact she blundered with bishop e5 and i
think rookie 7 didn't help the last few
moves were all going the wrong direction
for carissa rookie one
how much time should she have 10 seconds
10 seconds
right now 10 seconds rook to d7 was her
choice rook d7
uh oh
five moves each but this move bishop to
c8 followed by rook to d7 it's not wrong
don't connect with each other no wait a
minute give me that pawn root ac5 why
not
yeah i was about to say doesn't that hit
the bishop on e5 as well as the bishop
on c8 it does and it wins the game
seven seconds and he did it with seven
seven or six seconds six six
yeah
i have seen people go down to two and
one and each time
it's like like my heart skips a beat oh
look at those pawns
yeah all in a row
how do you continue the game right now
with black you don't the the
two bishops are hanging one of them is
going carissa is she's now she's looking
for desperado
uh she's worried
i don't know she's she's just hoping
five seconds left for karissa she has to
make a move bishop
bishop david iv
so she's looking at a queen d2
possibility
don't believe it i don't believe it
but what if i take on d4 right now
or what even rex c8 queen deter rook f1
can i just hold them
sorry
there were some oh i was just saying
what if rook takes the c8 queen d2 just
rock f1
let's see what his choice will be
and uh five seconds left and he took on
d4
that is the move
looks like a very good move i must say
it's a great move
unfortunately
yeah
check check and there's no way to put
the king yeah in order to put the king
see again bad
bad habits don't play with your pieces
don't play with your opponent's pieces
put them behind the clock rook takes d4
and rook take rook to c7
and andrew that is the move right now uh
will
will win the game and bishop d7 actually
is going to be met with a rook to e7 oh
nice or maybe even queen takes d4
at that point yes queen takes d4
is is killing rook roller nice rook c7
check bishop d7 queen takes d4 that will
he find it yes
no queen takes d4 first which is nine
enough
oh that's a brilliant move
because after knight takes d4 rookie
seven check and
it's gonna be a mate and unfortunately
queen g5 the inter mezzo is going to be
met with queen to g4 back
beautiful move by andrew he saw it all
um he calculated everything and i think
theresa right now carissa recognizing uh
it's all over it's only oh she resigned
wow she definitely had her moments there
she just missed
queen
d6 jack what a crazy six that is crazy
where do you like to take us tell ya
what
to tell you you said yeah
did i say tell ya
everything this is like a dream
ending for black nothing to discuss here
that's just
over over over next
absolutely next uh
whoa
um
wait a minute can i just push to a pawn
and call it's good
i'm not so sure
um
this pawn on
i'm just
knight takes bishop takes and you just
gotta make sure that you don't fall for
any trickies with bishop you know you
know what i mean you know but it takes
rookie one that's the problem oh
oh you still have some huge problems on
the phone i do
but uh we're going to pause our analysis
and go to christian who has a guest in
studio thank you yasser we are indeed
with a victor of today's round david
brosky david welcome to the show and
what a game to come back uh to our show
a game a victory against a wanderer
liang an incredible victory with the
white pieces did he surprise you with
the karaka and his approach um the car
wasn't a surprise like i mostly prepared
for e5
but uh
he likes to play this g5 in the car
sometimes
but he actually
a6 was a big surprise for me like i'm
trying to understand how you can come
why i want to combine a6 and g5 like i
can see the point
but
i'm not sure it's worth the tempo
and you kept up with your plan bishop to
d to knight to e1 a very typical plan in
this type of positions and then
target the newly created weaknesses on
the king side f4 let's keep it up let's
keep it going i'm not sure where he made
his mistake i'm
yeah and fg5 was nice because if he
takes in b3 then gh6
gh6 he has to go back to h8 and i
thought i have a lot of compensation
maybe i can do something more direct
like bishop d3 or i can just yeah it
takes b3 i have three pawns his his king
is h7 when he's coming in lines yeah i
know i was wondering if they can even
just go bishop d3 here like
this is looking really good it's looking
really good they're just you know
i've seen enough at least from a
practical perspective yeah yeah i i
don't know what the engines say
so of course he took back knight c1 f6
takes i was expecting bishop f6 hanging
onto the pawn
but like okay i understand that he wants
he wants to activate his his knight
but i'm not sure it was worth the pawn
because after after he took i wasn't too
sure where his compensation was i was
just a little confused so i think this
was at the moment where he could have
potentially activated his pieces in time
he missed a bit with the move queen to
d7 bishop to g6 seems to have been the
better movement okay and then knight of
three that was my f3 and knight f5 okay
bish before
yeah
and uh probably just go queen to e7
perhaps right now uh okay i guess e7 is
a better system
right
yeah
because but still he played the move
queen to d7 it made a lot of sense try
to activate the roots right yeah
nevertheless you managed to finally find
enough time to get your pieces
into play right now yeah how did you
assess it at this point uh at this point
i wasn't sure because my h5 bishop is a
little loose
but then at some point i think after
maybe 93 i realized i'm
more or less
winning here in my opinion at least yes
because i mean his attack is dead and
my knight in e5 is a monster and i have
an extra pawn
absolutely and uh let's keep on with the
moves i think another
fun moment came uh towards the
conversion phase when you played this
move g4 knight g3 queen to f2 rook to g7
i you had this uh brilliant move queen
to f6 did you spot it with the idea of
knight f7 knight h6 oh knight f7 knight
h6
oh oh oh yeah that's just
that just finishes the game the queen is
lost
it was just geometrically very pleasing
okay yeah
i mean what i did is completely winning
too because the status and just to
interrupt you for a second we do have a
massive result in this one rochelle who
did win her game against her good friend
jennifer you let's go back to the game
and uh you did take on g3 this is
winning as well very easily winning as
well
david congratulations a big victory
against the rating uh favorite of the
event how do you feel right now after
six rounds thank you i know i'm very
happy with this game you know i was
minus two going to this round that was
that was pretty bad you know after
getting hit by a train in round one i
haven't really found hadn't really found
my form but
you know i'm really happy because this
is my biggest scalp in quite a while you
know by rating being at 2 600 is always
nice but especially you know in these
circumstances like i understood that i
had a target on my back and he wanted to
take some risks but you know that's part
of chess still three rounds to go
maintain the momentum yeah right now and
we'll see you tomorrow yes thank you our
congratulations david and more results
are coming in uh
well
andrew hong did
win his game against curry say if it was
a very very lovely game back and forth
but it was a back door so
missed opportunities
and other uh
three decisive games already in the
juniors by the way and a draw between
the two igors
beautiful
and let's see anyone else
oh yeah jennifer you my pick
she had four out of five going into
today's round rochelle wu had three
out of five but rochelle wins what a
message and victor uh
they both and for sophie
this is like a dream come true like
that is true uh talia has a chance and
likely to go uh
with a victory over alice by the way uh
he mentioned david mentioned that
christopher yes
maybe winning and i i thought it was
going to
i thought at one time it was closer to a
draw but now it just looks winning
this night ending
just looks like it's just over
uh the last move was g4 g5 he's just
played the uh black christopher trying
to activate that poor king yeah well
it's not that it's driving away this
knight so you can go knight f5 check and
take the pawn then you'll be two pawns
or
as mentioned it's these uh pawns
on the wings before how do you call them
the pants the running pants how do you
call them
i've heard that um i've never used that
uh i just say you know the outside pass
pawn or
the a or the h pawn but knight f5 check
king c before we move too far away i
just want to mention that um
talia is supposed to it will be playing
um sophie in the last round exactly yes
it's going to be heated yes
that is it king c5 and now it's going to
be a race
there's no race there's no race you take
on b5 i go to g2 keep connection with
the pawn on f4 and then i just push my
pawn i love that move knight g2
it's strange how very often the knights
are not on good squares on the
fianchetto squares meaning g2 b2 g7 b7
but this case knight g2 eyeballs the
pawn on f4 just gets out of the way of
the h-pawn
and knight g2 nice move
love that move
and by the way i think maybe even knight
f3 instead of knight g2 taking advantage
of the fact that your knight actually i
don't see a good way to get to f2 or h1
and he's played knight e3 stopping
stopping knight g2 and i think it kind
of uh can i still just go back knight to
five and just yes or knight f3
yes to support the pawn push right right
so if we go knight f5 yeah a white is
definitely going knight f1 right
uh just to uh in order to cover the pawn
uh now we're thinking that well we could
run with the king up the board that
would be nice or i was just concerned
can i just play knight t6 and just dare
the devil they're the devil so the idea
is that tags
now
now what did you call them running pants
i i haven't i'm trying to remember how
you call these guys i do remember
reading something like times and the
redskins and game book don't
bishop trying to control both pawns
right the running pants yeah i don't
know why you call them running pants
just clicks yeah yeah i have heard that
or read that before but but
[Laughter]
well but i like knight f3 just because
you need to get the knight to f2
right so take on b5 and h4 knight to d1
maybe but christopher has let me just
refresh my by the way the juniors
they're very decisive they don't want to
draw i tell you every round they swing
for the fences um
knight three
and uh we had the woman of the hour with
christian let's go for it
rochelle uh big victory for you against
one of your good friends uh jenny for
you now how does that feel we had the
discussion here on the panel how do you
feel after you play against your best
friends um
i mean like
i like i don't
i don't know like it's um it feels good
to win but at the same time like i um
sympathize for her so like
because i know if it were in my shoes i
would not be that happy to lose so
absolutely a difficult uh moment but
still that takes you to four out of six
a very respectable
result for you let's take a look at
today's game take us through the
critical moments it did feel like she
surprised you out of the opening was
that the case um
i mean i think
i don't think she was expecting um e5
after c4 actually
um i think that were we might have both
been out of theory i'm not sure because
we both started thinking pretty early on
um
[Music]
and did you remember this line did you
study this line with your coach not
really
um i think i looked at it really quickly
and because like i was looking at like a
lot of things she plays like many things
as white so i didn't like
really focus on one thing in particular
i just like reviewed a lot of things
let's keep going queen to e2
and she was uh
really putting a lot of pressure on the
king side did you feel that way as well
were you concerned at all about this
pawn push
i was a little bit concerned
about g4
like not not here but like eventually
uh
i don't think i should have played b6
actually um
maybe if i just like went bishop d7
immediately
because
i didn't like
i didn't really have a solid plan here i
wanted to possibly put my bishop on b7
and go c5 eventually
and get the bishop to c6 right yeah
but like i feel like it never really
works like if i move my bishop to the
um to b7 she has like knight f5 stuff
and it's actually really annoying to
deal with
and this was the critical moment i think
um not bishop to b7 but how you uh
played in the game bishop to d7 and now
she played this move knight to b3 we
were a bit surprised yeah i was
surprised too i thought maybe she'd go
knight f3 in the night e5 um and that
was in fact the best movie in the
position yeah
um
i think maybe she was like scared of
stuff like bishop g4
and then
like
it probably does not work but it's like
it's kind of worrisome to be honest like
if you take
um knight takes oh he's definitely yeah
um
like knight takes g3
i know i would be a little bit concerned
if i were white here
no there's a lot of knights around yeah
the white king
okay so
um after she played knight b3
i played c5
because um
i completely forgot about bishop takes
f6 immediately i thought she was gonna
play like bishop e5 and then i was gonna
play rook takes e5
um
and i thought that position would be
like
interesting
you're definitely getting a lot of play
for us yeah strange
but yeah i just complete like
right when i played it i was like wait
you can actually take my knight
immediately but c5 in fact it was the
best movie really by far in the position
yes so take on f6 g takes f6
and this position already the engine was
saying that it's favorable to you did
you feel that way no
i thought i was like um trying to defend
at this point like
i
thought that instead of taking on e4 she
might play queen h5
um
i was kind of worried about this
position
wait but do you have knight takes g3 is
that a move um i thought king takes rook
takes e3 king f2
and you don't have queen takes f4 is
that not enough
it looks so dangerous though
bishop f3 bishop c6
i mean can she go like bishop g4 yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah maybe it's enough maybe rook to e8
doesn't give you
enough compensation even there
very scary stuff
in this position for white so let's go
back
she took on e4 she decided to eliminate
that knight
and uh i want to take you to the moment
after bishop takes h3
i was not sure about bishop takes h3 at
all but like what was your concern right
now what was the the move that you were
concerned about i was a little bit
concerned about g4 g4 okay i like i i
didn't see anything after it
but i was like this kind of scary
um
definitely looks scary but actually g4
was fine for you now yeah the only move
for her was in fact
looking to h8 yes
e5 did you spot this move
i don't have bishop g4 knight e4
well like
i think i thought i had the queen takes
d1 yes yes queen takes d1 and now the
question is how is this end game after
knight xf6
and queen takes d1 and it does seem that
white has enough compensation after
knight xc8 maybe not even compensation
yeah
still wild stuff and she played this
move f5
did she just simply miss bishop takes a
5 digit no she definitely saw it because
she spent a lot of time there that's
what we thought but it didn't make a lot
of sense
because now after bishop takes a five
you just defend yeah yeah
and you're two pawns out i mean she was
in like heavy time pressure so i don't
really blame her
let's keep going and after that
smooth uh conversion at least that's how
it felt for us
rochelle big victory for you four out of
six sophie seems to be going to six out
of six wait really what will it take to
catch uh with that lady
um i mean i don't think that really
depends on me i think that happens on
her
do you still have to play with her or
not i already lost
got it
well rochelle congratulations huge
victory for you we'll see you tomorrow
thank you
our congratulations as well rachelle
that's very very nice victory over a
tough competitor
talia again
she really looks like she's got
a dominating position in at any time and
i think it's going to happen very soon
by the way you you scoop up scoop up
that pawn and again the this pawn this
construction of the pawn on e4 the
bishop on b3 is keeping these rooks
tethered uh you you would love to play
rook c1 and get your rook behind the
pawn but unfortunately any time you do
that and allow the pawn to get to a2 yep
there's nothing to discuss it just goes
to a2 the rook will go behind and it
will be a a coronation so so
king f1 what you played what's how how
do you how do you do it did is king f1
on the board yes okay very good can i
just go king g5 kg5 it's okay let's um
oh excuse me i don't think i i did it
right i apologize let me just
let me just get king f1 king g5 sorry
let's go king e1
right rushing over
and scoop up the ball so now you scooped
up the pawn do i have
jack
well i'm thinking about exchanging the
rooks the bishops
with our bishop to d1
okay
so now maybe i can start with king d2
king d2
even though king d2 is allows rook c4 uh
but let's check the camera of
christopher you because i do have a
feeling we're going to see a resignation
very soon in this one oh that's three
pawns to the goodness
not only that but your knight is stuck
on h1
oh
dear
dear dear i think we're going to see a
resignation guys
yeah
[Music]
and christopher eu is surging right now
he drew that game in the second round
and after that four victories in a row
to take him to five and a half out of
six wow this is just incredible stuff
coming from this young man who is
surging through the rankings at only 15
years of age he's close to 2 600.
right now feeder rating
that is just an incredible performance
and truly
alejandro called it i'll i'll have to
give it to to alejandro i don't often do
that but
he calls
recognizes uh alejandra's genius he he
felt that christopher is due for a big
result and that's exactly what we're
seeing right now he's playing confident
chess he doesn't make mistakes and he's
taking his opponents to school and by
the way move f5 i really like because
the knight on e4
is making the japanese word is to suji a
kind of a domination over the night on
h1 nice
yeah to suji the knight which was
practically mushy exactly and two extra
pawns i'm a little bit surprised that
justin is even playing on because the
move f7 f5 is a really good few more
minutes to completely count the turns
right right that's the way that goes by
the way there's one game remaining
guys guys no no don't forget about the
rule of the set we need to see the pain
we need to see the resignation
right don't move away from the
resignation
some cruelty going on there by the way
excuse me but balaji
is a
clear advantage
uh
uh bellagi knight to g3 well well that's
a resignation right it's a leather yeah
come on let's just pull my straight and
just get my king in there and exactly my
cat could do this i like it we're we're
playing grand master chess here yes come
on justin
right
uh you you know that was like the old
soviet joke uh the old soviet joke is
the
the the man goes to the beach where he
plays his dog
chess
and there's the right there's the
resignation uh fist bump there
that's king of six
i kind of like the fist bump more than
yeah yeah the handshake the fist bump
well congratulations to christopher's he
continues his winning ways five and a
half out of six
putting his signature on these
uh
u.s junior championships
sorry just to finish the joke so the man
goes to the beach he plays his dog chess
and all the beach goers go and look wow
this is fantastic this is incredible
look the dog is making the moves and
he's playing chess very well
and the man gets upset with the
beachgoers and he says
why so brilliant i'm leading three to
one
oh boy nobody sorry
somebody there was like a dog that could
actually like i don't i remember the
exact details it was like one of the
dogs that could i've heard of chicken
playing tic-tac-toe just no no no i
think it was just like something on
something with this owner on the stream
it was kind of fun i can't remember
anything i've seen i've seen a lot of
cats play with chess pleases
but
as the players have reached their time
control again four out of four decisive
games in the juniors they are swinging
for the fences we're gonna take a break
and we'll see on the other side
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end has
established itself as a premier global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments including the us
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the us and world chess halls
of faith
cutting edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art innovative programming
explores the intersection of chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries
the world chess hall of fame is nothing
you expect and everything you love three
different galleries and a premier gift
shop highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the st louis chess campus visit
stlchestcampus.org
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
coverage of round six of the three
us championships the girls the juniors
the seniors and we have seen some
really decisive blows dorsal i don't
know
but the players really seem like they
after the rest day they're ready to go
really rip roaring and in the uh junior
section i think we've already had four
decisive games
the women's has featured a huge victory
for rochelle oh jennifer you that was a
big victory for rochelle
and i'm seeing a winning position
in the game between sofia
and rue yang now if sofia wins
she will be scoring a phenomenal six out
of six that's just like wow she and
there you see her so focused and intense
she knows it
and you exactly she knows it and uh wow
what a all you could do is just kind of
tip your hat and say very very well done
um and i think we
did just see a result in nick the
fermion's game versus right dmitry
guravich i think
nick just resigned oh right is he
dropped he he was two pawns down
in a rook and upon end game as he
realized oops and in fact
mr garvey although we've had two draws
in the seniors the three remaining games
all look to be vic to be decisive
uh you just mentioned nick going down
but it looks to me like joe benjamin is
going down
as well as gregory kaidanov gregory
started with a huge advantage out of the
opening but shibalov has fought his way
back actually i'm sorry uh when we get a
chance it would be lovely if we can go a
little deep like i feel like i'm just
kind of um i can't actually remember
that game at all
i think we're just gonna brush up on it
a little here and there that was this
bishop f4 yeah yeah
and then we stopped we left it after the
opening and so yeah uh would you like to
start with that or would you like to
stay with the ladies for a little bit
sure i'm just saying that we we we have
uh
to my eyes a completely winning position
for shabbat love all right he's uh
material ahead and well these two pass
bonds should should be decisive uh so
and i'm thinking that uh
joel benjamin
is a losing uh the whole point was in
this position what maxine has done is
forced a queen trait essentially
and if uh
max had calculated right his idea was
just to bring his king
up the board shoulder black's king and
then
uh move towards the b-pawn
that was why we saw g5
by joel
so joel's hope
is that uh he could use as h-pawn as a
distraction but i don't think
that's going to work i don't think so
um i mean i don't think can i just trade
queens and just bring the king in
uh after pawn to g5 can i just do queen
takes except for pawn takes f4 just
king walk to the other side
yeah absolutely why not i don't really
see um i'm not sure i'm not sure
i mean even on the well let's go let's
just see what the all right
what the
outcome is going to be i think joel is
losing but
uh you have to
now
there's no way that this is a race right
like there's nothing
but even if it's not just king d4
exactly it's over uh you your one
weakness will be protected by the rook
on b3 queen takes f4 looks like an easy
win for max
uh sorry the ladies
still four games going oh my oh my yes
so but guys a very important game i mean
that one let's take what talia is doing
because oh no to me it doesn't look
convincing at all oh no my girl why
she didn't win the pawn on h5 no why not
good question but
king was on f6 all she had to just come
g5 just eat it
um
no it's not convincing at all uh
but okay how
how do you actually have any advantage
right now
like what do you take on b3 i i take
with the rook
that's fine um but now i go rk2
and i go check that's okay i take
i go king
d2 okay
i think that's just king c3 rook b3 and
we force a draw right um
just checking for a moment just a second
okay that's fine you want to
invade i do no no no no no no no no no
no no no i won't allow you to do that
yeah that's right
i go king d3
i'm sorry
oh you're gonna give me f2 okay
even though maybe no no no forget about
it yes sir uh i apologize i go king e1
okay yeah and then uh d4 check right
right
k5 d5 k4 d5 that's what i mean yeah yes
and if this pawn were gone then there'd
be something to discuss with this pond
still on the board
this is a draw very easy whoa
talia very strange decision not to win
a pawn that was on offer and uh she
didn't make a move let's see what did
she take back with let me just uh
refresh she took me the pawn
a takes b3
but now once again let's bring the king
let's bring the king in king absolutely
king
put the king and this rook
i know it's a long long way
but still you start thinking you start
do these thoughts go through your head
like hey if you're not gonna take my h5
pawn maybe i'll take your h thing on the
other hand telia has a plan right i mean
it's pretty convincing if she could ever
get her king to f3
that would be huge i dare say then what
like that i'm there
i've arrived thank you i've arrived uh i
guess it's king e2 king d5 king here
though
and also by the way i can also hit you
no
yes i can hit with you with a check
that's actually a pretty cool yeah
that's actually a pretty uh checkmate
same as the other one exactly reciprocal
checkmate okay
interesting so how is that end game so
let's say rook d5 okay five rook b5
let's keep going in that i i wouldn't
actually want to trade queens i would
probably play king b3 myself
king d3 myself now e5 let's say e5
it's
very unpleasant but i don't think
e5 are
wow
well
oh all right we we have a man that wants
to get involved right now in the past
analysis the winner of uh today's round
dmitry gurevich is with us dimitri
welcome back to the show uh big victory
for you i wasn't hoping to be back
well you are and you are in uh
extraordinary fashion actually first
let's take a look at your game and then
we'll get to the analysis of that end
game as well so let's start with your
game tell us what were the critical
moments the critical moments was when he
played f3 it was a critical
critical moment because nick never
played this move as far as i know he
always played bishop c4 and he was great
and he beat me a number of times i think
i beat him once or something
and uh so he's there was one you know i
loved surgeon when
when fischer started playing people
playing it i i really like so it's like
many many young guys at that time
uh and i played them for both colors
soldiers
was a difficult move for me because i
always took on d4 and played g6
i think i was lucky to beat lazaro
brazon years ago when he was world
junior champion when he wasn't it was
already good
and uh it worked out and then i kept
doing it in low rated tournaments
and it was successful but uh it's not a
good position i think and and recently
in chicago and the kid also gardesi uh
he's low rated but he is very very very
talented he
crashed me in that position so i thought
i'm not going to do it again i want to
but i didn't learn it properly i i knew
that
it's two moves this is six so e5 i much
rather play e6 is my style but uh if i
was a better move probably more you know
reliable so so you decide to go with a
little objective precision more or less
so i didn't study it doesn't enough
because usually you don't do enough
so but i felt the position is okay and
then i remember a little bit i i knew
two great guys uh
i was working with victor kochen and i
was i can't even say that argentina was
friend of michelle thought because he
had thousand friends thousands of
friends so i was one of those i mean
and um in 1988 i saw
seven
times in four different countries so it
was very fortunate anyway once i know
that albeit cautionary some line is
very late in life not in the beginning
with a5 bishop b5 knight a7 something
like that so it was something which i
remember oh i'm thinking about two my
favorite people to my favorite chess
players and i might even get to this
type of position so i it was okay it was
okay and then when he didn't do that i
thought well that gives me more chances
probably that i'm not sure i know that
nick also didn't not a big specialist
this position but he's a great citizen
player so
i thought uh he's he's you know in
better shape but that was okay was okay
so still the best thing you can uh
expect in this position i was very happy
with this position because
yeah i thought that this is it if if for
you know i thought if he doesn't take
i'm very happy if he plays bishop of two
i was going to play bishop g5 where he
is e4 and all this kind of tactics for
black so i thought if he takes a pawn
which i expect yeah this is e4 like g4
knight g3 something like this takes
takes queen h4 so it looks good so
and uh usually i get this kind of
positions in kinzini and with white and
she have been a lot of trouble so you
know they said anyway so i was very
happy with this position because uh if
you can get something yeah this is it
because you have a square and one pawn
and you think you give you forget about
the pawn yeah if they pay the price they
don't mind i mean so this is at least i
can play so at some variation for
example after bishop of six uh this is a
line
uh uh after bishop of six he plays
bishop g6 it's a fourth it could be six
i know i i i what what do i do oh yeah
play bishop
something like queen b6 check c5 knight
take c5 so it's it's working for black
yeah so he played this move uh rook to
f1 let's keep going yes sir uh
you know i thought this is a black
what do you say rokofan no let's keep
going uh oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
no this is fine if bring the rock okay
to eat like achieve gold oh this is i
didn't realize it's a blunder right away
i knew that my passion is fine yes and
then i as small as i saw i couldn't
believe it what is it which one should
be three takes takes queen f2 yeah so so
this is a bad position it's probably
lost it doesn't mean i'm going to win it
but objectively it is
it is a
good position but i don't think you
relinquish the pressure at any moment in
this game went on to win well i know
that it's tactics for wait if i do
something wrong as i usually did in the
past a lot of things oh you do do make
one mistake one little mistake yes
that's it situation changes you don't
have too much time and you blunder
happened to me millions of times so
you're still careful oh of course no
doubt about it but that's it you know
this is the moment i saw this variation
yeah i made quincy just in case one more
one more move why not yeah yes yes
and this i saw the end game because i
realized i might have something better
but i should be so fortunate to have
this so end game is supposed to be
winning and and then i thought i can do
this so you can do that i can go [ __ ]
ponegamer some relations and why do i do
that because
sometimes it's that miracle draw one of
them it's all about the calculation in
those angles i am just just a teacher
there's some miracle drawers and you
don't don't expect to do to win because
you have extra pawn yes this happens but
this is a very good question for example
king f7 is one of those same games kind
of seven instead of king of six
and then uh
uh rook take g3 kin f7 uh then rocket g3
rogue g6
uh exchange and um
probably and this is winning position
i mean 99 99 sometimes these are drawing
yes
percent but who care i mean i have one
end game that's a rock and a game so why
should i uh even think about because
skin panel game is easier no sometimes
it's not kin for negan i told my
students always it's always some some a
miracle thing you never know what will
happen and
it's always an adventure yes yes because
it's very concrete you know that is you
the guy has a queen and he beats you no
matter who you are marcus carson
99
but two pawns in a rook and game well in
this position you know that was too much
raw connections
two points no guarantee yes
it happens in some positions especially
classical rock and my students just had
that rook and pawns
cna or
hnf
it is in between its kind of position uh
which the top second top player in the
world paul kerry's hero the book here
but this is a mistake so the world
champion says about the second or third
role player that he makes mistake in
this thing that means how complex it is
yeah i have my own stories
so but this is it's a one position yeah
dimitri uh a great result so far for you
you're getting closer to those
leadership positions how do you assess
your chances are you thinking about it
at all absolutely is it too early oh
it's not even
not even a question for me i have to
play
three players and
i mean
two two players are legends you know one
is great player he's not professional
but he's also a very strong player so
i'm not even thinking about it well you
are a legend yourself as well so
keep the momentum keep the energy going
and we'll see you in the next few rounds
sure will be exciting for sure
absolutely our congratulations to you
dima very very nice thank you
and uh as we see two wins classic two
draws but we're expecting joel benjamin
to go down against max delugey so that
it will be three wins in the seniors
uh there as four
and because larry christensen drew it
kind of opened up the door essentially
for other players to join him so we'll
see if max can reel in this victory but
because of dima's win he's tight with
larry i have to say i love the hats i
know the hat is great so cool i mean
i wish i could pull off last night yeah
uh when when i played in the us
championship in key west we all had
those hats
because key west you know you've got the
hot sun you gotta have uh gotta have a
hat to keep you cool do you recommend it
yasser do you recommend key west oh
definitely it's a
gorgeous gorgeous uh and
and i and i did the drive
yeah i had a flight but i i wanted to
drive on those bridges and it was really
amazing because it's like you're in the
middle of the ocean it's like ridiculous
and the bridges are miles long
and you drive across the bridge in the
middle of the ocean it almost is a
surreal feeling i loved it
that's such a well now that i can't
legally drive there we go
now you know what
excuse me guys is alice lee better right
now
oh no there is
good talia played rook b5 and now rook
takes b3 came as a shocker
the board this is a cold shower and
white is just simply going to be a pawn
up in the ensuing end game wow you're
right you're right she's blundered rook
on she could have played rook on the
6 rook b6 to b5 and there would have
been that alice spotted the opportunity
that i mean you were winning the whole
game and right now you're fighting
for equality this is a psychological
situation in which you don't find
yourself very often and when you do
you need extreme mental resilience to
get over it right because with only five
minutes left on the clock this is going
to be a difficult defense
oh my goodness when you
again because you're carrying the
baggage of i was winning the whole game
i was winning the whole game
and then you really really start kicking
yourself and usually uh it it isn't it's
like you're not just you don't make just
one mistake it comes in bunches i have
to ask um as a chess squeal legend
[Music]
usually that means like you're dead and
dusted there's a nice little brass back
there's a legend yes what what what's
your question
as a chess grandmaster thank you
and well someone who people look up to
if you're one of your students was in
talia's shoe and you know that advantage
and then poof
and then yeah then let's say it just
keeps going downhill and she ends up
well god forbid losing right how would
you try to like help him out after the
game i i would cry alongside
i mean because there's just no other way
of putting it
you just i mean it's just terrible and
you just go ah
we've all been there yeah and
uh chess players
especially experience grand masters
i remember
when i had done some martial arts and i
said well why do they call it a black
belt yeah
why do you have a black belt in martial
arts he says well you know all that
means is that you've worked so hard
your white belt has turned black it's
got all the dirt on it right
and that's what i think a grand master
means you know you have chess mastery
but the more blunders
the more mistakes you've made
then they give you more titles
like and if you've lost a thousand games
you know they're going to call you a
super g
good you know so
it you you just have to take your
your lumps of coal and that's what this
is right now italia uh has to defend an
awkward position from a winning position
but we have a special guest in studio
we're going to jump to christian
we are indeed with alex chabolov after a
crazy game against kaidanov alex you are
on the back foot from the beginning in
the opening did he surprise you with
this move bishop to f4 were you aware of
this trend
on the contrary i know this move very
well i played it with white as
as recent as chicago open
[Music]
and
i know exactly what white is uh looking
for and
uh
i was looking for the ways to avoid the
standard position after uh d6 knight
takes c6 and c and c4 yeah yeah and then
i know very well that you have to play
e5 bishop b7 bishop e6 and at the right
moment very important to play a5 for
black to not allow white to play b4
but that position
is really really hard to break through
especially against gregory so i was
looking for some creative way to
make it a little bit more complicated
but i think the cost
was too much
the cost was definitely height yeah the
yeah it didn't look good i mean 97
already uh yeah well what can you do
and uh the game developed well
definitely felt like it's going white's
way
he was managing to develop his pieces
while you are still struggling to find
the best placement still i didn't really
see the direct way to
i think here a big moment came where he
could have played the move bishop takes
e6 did you consider this
yes and take c6 and just simply defend
the pawn with queen d3
oh really yeah just see no i mean if
that's the way then it's
it's not human not easy
it's just like yeah and just bank
everything just give up the bishop and
play a quiet move yeah yeah and then go
f5 g4 g5 h5 and okay just say that i
have the attack while you don't i mean
yeah i
believe but not easy definitely not no
no that that really didn't
didn't occur to me that
that's the way
but now now i see why also b4 if you put
it on e7 yeah no obviously yeah not not
a good one but he decided to play the
more natural c5 and took yeah here i was
more or less
uh
i calm down because uh
you know what doesn't have a direct
attack anymore position stabilized right
yeah so
so you are feeling pretty confident at
this point yeah i thought i put my
bishop on c4 and then i'm not at the
risk to lose and then i will you know
try to
wear him down a little bit because uh
but
yeah i think h i i know in the game it
felt like a h5 was a
he losing up himself while he gave me g5
score for the bishop
and
if porn would remain on h4 i would have
trouble like activating my bishops to
find some way to make progress yeah
but i think maybe bishop is six but six
and
still things were quite complicated
really i thought here uh
i was already like winning but uh
yes i think up after this yeah the
critical moment and we had so many games
uh crazy games going on that we lost
track of yours at one point now were
there any critical moments that you felt
you spotted during the game um
no obviously yeah i think ah5 that was
the moment when i thought that he
went too far yeah the pawn remains on h4
and he makes it to move 40 it does not
allow me to activate my bishops i
don't think black can break through
anytime soon but
after h5 is just
surprisingly hard to defend pawns
anymore like
the rooks don't have too many squares
so yeah to me i felt like h5 was a
mistake h5 the critical moment alex uh
big victory for you with the black
pieces now you're getting closer to
those leadership position only half a
point behind larry and uh dimitri
gravity yeah it's
getting hot and uh military guru it's a
very surprising you know um
factor so we'll see how he first
in the last two rounds so
uh no i'll take my chances too there we
go congratulations once again guys any
questions for alex no just uh our our
congratulations chef a nice win
looks like uh well i keep up the good
work
thank you yes yes sir absolutely
and uh where would you like to take us
uh well let's take a quick look at the
one remaining game for the legends yes
that would be max
versus joel he's two pawns up and just
because the base pawn could be
defended so nicely after rook d3 and
rook
c3 i thought that white was just winning
the game that uh still kind of feels
winning
yeah
[Music]
yeah
too many pawns uh extra pawns
orbs or
[Music]
just push them baby
i would
this is a little work
remember what uh dmitry gurvich said
coming in he said sometimes you have
these winning rook and pawn endings and
you transpose them into
winning
king and pawning games
only problem is sometimes there's a
miracle
in the king of pawning games and you
don't win it
any miracles here
christian well
i don't think so no there's no miracles
happening in that one i understand f5
will be met by rook shack i get that
part whoa whoa the evaluation bar sorry
what happened i just saw the evaluation
bird jump
for me sorry
no king to c4 yeah i think it's the easy
way to make a bomb no no no no no no no
no okay
but it's all about the uh the kings uh
and pawns end game right so rocking to
e6 how do we feel about that do we go
king to c5 and allow
black to take on d7
rook takes c7 we take and king to d5 and
is there
f6
and then king to e4 and how is that
exactly it should be winning right
for sure
yes it's winning because we get to f5
and then we will have another bullet
with the move f4 to force the king to go
either b7 or g7 right uh just thinking
how is it you get some crazy positions
like this
where i want it to be
white's move so i can play f5 check
right
but you don't know i i you know what i
mean i'm gonna i'm gonna make a bad move
for just a moment sorry so i can just
set up the position i want
i'm doing it very badly i can't
apologize
uh
golly
boy did i do this badly
uh yes or how many i know
what do we need here exactly i wanted to
get to this position to say that maybe
f5 check would be uh
uh
do it the soul tree i think it's still
winning though i just even this is if
this is still losing then there's
another trick i think so just king e3
king f3 yeah okay this is still winning
so there's
yeah all the way to f6 invade via g6 no
there was no hope should max win this
game then i'm thinking there's going to
be a three-way tie for first it will be
yes it's going to be max dmitry guravich
and larry christensen and joel benjamin
is going to be having a disastrous event
i have to say exactly
nothing to be done wow
okay
three wins in the seniors and what's
going on in the italia game have we um
have we seen some i feel depressed about
this one i know it was like she was
really
uh
she's under pressure right now and i
have to say a difficult moment right now
because easily oh that's not italia game
right that is the sophie mori suzuki
game in which
she does seem to be breaking through but
this one right now a big moment because
you can take on h5 right can i right
and let's wait to see whether she's
going to go for it take it take it touch
it you're almost there girl
but that's not a great move ah
this is what the point i'm trying to
make if you do take on h5 e4 after e4
she will be suffering that end game rook
g5 and then king to e3
that's not going to be an easy end game
to defend so the right move actually
right now is to go just simply rook to
a1 and go back but that's not easy so
just hold just hold just wait all right
but this is not easy she will take on h5
very natural very human move but now
after f4 well
three minutes and 20 seconds on the
clock and she plays it immediately e4
immediately yeah
is the only move right and then comes
king e3 with the idea of keeping f3 it's
it's starting to be oh what else
this might just be losing yeah
you might be able to maintain equality
so for example rook to g5
came into e3 and then rook back to h5
you know what i'm thinking okay yeah i
understand what you're saying very
difficult by the way
one takes and then rook back yeah
so rook g5
king to e3 and rook to h5 back now
why is that the only move because i want
to meet whenever you put the king on f4
so just
i will teleport to f4 i want to have the
move rook to h2 at that point to an
attack to counter with an attack on the
pawn on f2 if i don't have that
then my position collapses
maybe uh you could show it on your board
because all we're seeing is the light
board so all of that analysis you're
saying uh yes so this is what i'm seeing
right now rook two h5 right now you can
take take and then king to f4 whenever
we get to this position yeah
i need to be able to play the move rook
to h2 clear anything else and the rook
capturing on f5 is going to be game over
because that's true also you're losing
the pawn on g4 and the rook on f5 is
going to defend the pawn on f2 so you
have to be ready at this point
to play the move rook to h2 and even
this is not very clear whether you hold
or not nevertheless it does seem like
you're getting quite close to that okay
difficult moment for these two ladies
right now well especially for talia who
once again she has been playing
for a win this whole game from the
beginning from the opening phase and
right now she's on the back foot right
and with only one minute and 30 seconds
left guys right
yeah this is uh this is a nervy moment
but we were also looking at rook g5
kidney 3
and that felt very good for alice too
like really winning chances that's it
that's that's that's the moment yeah
yeah i mean again king e3 and then you
have to go back g5 king e3 this would be
losing king and pawn end game that's a
losing king opponent game exactly so
instead of her instead of pawn takes
pawn here maybe just struck back to h5
to h1
that gives up the f5 pawn
i don't think that's the right decision
she played rook h1 rook to h1 just
giving up the f5 pawn just like that
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
uh i i don't see it i i don't think that
feels like a big gift take take take
okay
is she thinking of h5h4 trying to reduce
all the pawns
um we might be at a table base very
quickly she's winning right now she is
winning she's winning this position is
already waiting what a turnaround for
alice leaves i had a very awkward
tournament all these boards are going
whoosh
spinning and what's crazy is for sophie
her two nearest rivals would both lose
oh
wow with four with three rounds to go
she would be
almost two points clear this is clear of
the field
wow that's a huge advantage she can
basically clinch the title tomorrow
oh yes if she does then jennifer you she
plays against jenny for you if she
eliminates another contender right and
rochelle wu or talia do not win i mean
this is over exactly exactly and she's
putting the finishing touches right now
let me just
bring that game into our screen
somehow we are in a quick pretty there's
pawn ending
but
not too much to discuss here it's all
about the a
train express i love that the a train
the a train
i mean it's going fast thank you yeah
watching uh the boys yasser yes yes you
like the eight races the chess bras uh
the
twitch
twitch
amman is playing in the
canadian open
i know i know but boy i tell ya uh
now 83 and this is it
i i'm seeing so much excitement about
the olympiad in india
so many people are
ready to go right right
i mean how cool and there goes a3 her
next move is going to be like queen a1c
[Music]
h4
check check a2 and
what a dominant performance
it's really really remarkable stellar
just simply stellar right now the
unstoppable uh sophie morris suzuki
she's getting ready
she's dancing
excited what's happening boy
what is happening right
i see uh
could be nervousness could be low time
slash b3 check yeah that one sounds
pretty good
i mean just push the pawn next
to check and burn push push push
yes
yes let's go
a2 makes a lot of sense followed by
queen to b to n there's actually nothing
even now help me out here um
sophie's rating
she is
her invitation rating i'm not sure uh
i i mean when
when christian was telling us about the
gladiators and all the things she's done
i was looking at her successes and not
really looking at her
uh invitation already maybe we can get
that information
all right so queen to b2 now she
definitely did not come in this she
didn't favorite no she came into the
event as the seventh
seventh by reading uh seventh seed yes
wow
that makes her victory
all the more
extraordinary
and all she has to do is push the pawn
right now
i just feel like the move queen b3 was
okay i mean
you know
i'm splitting hairs but you are you are
still i mean you know this is
resignation time right h that's fine
that's going to be one check and in the
meantime i'm actually going to check
mate you can actually let's eat that
can i just say pawn takes pawn
forget about it no no no
why give your opponent
h6 and don't touch that pawn that's all
you have to do
oh yeah that's kind of cute if king
takes the queen and shit's going to
swing
oh boy
go king h7 followed by checkmate with
two queens right
very nice and
she's looking for that second queen is
she going to take it and put it on the
board
yes
yes there's
yes there's a queen on the board nicely
done
and we expect that after age six
king h7 king h7
then it will be time to resign
she will
hide the king right beautifully done
and this might be
resignation time
six out of six sophie
she's playing for a caruana tomorrow
nice
can't she do it so we have a hat trick
that's three in a row ah so what's four
in a row yeah that's what i'm thinking
too i think uh
ronaldo
the football player soccer player uh had
four in a game but i don't know what the
cuatro goal i mean to help me out here
uh christian i have no idea
yeah we well uh
car you wanna i don't know seven
carolina is a seven in a row exactly
exactly well we'll we'll get our ace
crack producer tom
to uh
to to uh tell us and we have a guest
back to christian we we do indeed we are
here with maxine lughi after another
dominant performance with the white
pieces maxim congratulations big victory
against joel benjamin and that takes you
to the lead
collegiate how does that feel it feels
good it always it's always tough to play
joel i mean we played so many games it
was such an enormous
40 plus years of chess
that uh i i always feel a little nervous
playing him absolutely let's take a look
at the game yeah absolutely
joel doesn't feel like he's in his best
shape did you feel that way before the
round as well no i i think uh i think he
he didn't know the the line actually
kind of interesting because i didn't
expect him to play the ragozan but but
then he didn't know the line i actually
played this quite a lot
uh and i loved i i i
was trying to emulate magnus carlsen who
had this beautiful setup once of the
bishop e2 i think black supposedly
bishop e6 instead of queen g6 and then
uh he castled
and then uh after like place a6 which is
also i think the book move he played
against aronia and he played rook f
c one and that was such a beautiful
concept because the concept was that
he's gonna go bring the queen back to d1
and the queen bishop and knight will be
taking care of the king side while the
two rooks on the knight will be doing
the minority attack or some attack on
the queen side and
i i it was just lovely he won that game
but then you know of course black found
ways to deal with you know timing g5
correctly all the stuff
it's about
it's basically equal again but you know
very balanced and complicated but he
didn't know this and so he he was trying
to make this work but this just doesn't
work because
mainly because the knight actually wants
to go to d3 perhaps you also surprised
him by the fact that you didn't play
your usual london system yes it was a
big uh
big decision a big decision no i
actually was preparing against uh his
normal bogo indian and that's where my
big prep was
and and i decided not to play the london
first time with white in this tournament
in
two of these tournaments oh wow
i played for london
three years ago but okay you know
sometimes you know i i used to play
chess before you need a change before
retiring so i i do know some lines but
um yeah here uh it was interesting
i mean there
uh
well yeah queen b1 and queen b2 those
were the choices but yeah this clearly
is not great because of knight takes
pawn and there's a knight e2 check in
between
this whole thing and so
i my advantage will we didn't even
see this one we were actually looking at
b8 rook takes c6 and just uh
no there was actually a cool line that
he could have tried but it didn't work
for rock takes b7 and bishop to exist
yeah no there was a cool like instead of
queen d6 i think he could have tried uh
a6 instead of queen d6 right last move
so if he and this was a line that was
important rook c1 ace ace no not queen
rook
okay ace
a6
queen b7
rook b8
uh
yeah queen takes c7
and rook c8
the idea is he wants to play bishop c4
but now i have immediately
the very nice move queen f4
and on bishop c4 bishop
followed by the t3 and that that was
kind of like clincher so
you know that i'm like okay
knight on e1 is doing great work
the two extra points should should be
okay so uh yeah so he played queen d6
rook c1
going back to b1
yeah and and now yeah now this is
typical joel like finding amazing
chances like uh uh in in really bad
positions um
and then just to interrupt you for a
second we did get a result in this game
between alice lee and talia cervantes
alice lee won with an unexpected victory
wow against talia cervantes wow what a
game this was wow done let's keep going
yeah so the key is to protect the c4
square and now
so now i was wondering how
uh
how to play rook a3 or queen a3 at the
right time like the rook one eight can't
move because of those ones that's why
uh so i played uh what they play h3 h3
yeah and and joel immediately starts
using that i mean it's amazing how
how with like five minutes left he finds
motives and of course rook g6 is the
idea so now i played a very tricky move
queen c2 very very tricky this was like
this is my his punishment for being in
time pressure because now knight f3
works in all lines it of course on queen
h3 there's queen takes g6 oh very nice
and and uh but the problem is how to
deal with knight e5 so
logically you'll play knight c4 but
after knight support would just take the
knight and play five yeah on the game
over so so he plays
yeah and and again on queen australia
with queen music so he has to play so he
plays queen d5 but then rook c5 and
again the same tactic of queen f3 queen
g6
um everything just falls into place yeah
so so this becomes really really bad but
amazing how he yeah h4 i don't know yeah
i was
i don't know there's so many i mean
obviously instead of h4 i could have
played uh f4 maybe well i couldn't play
that f4 um
yeah i could have played f4 but
okay but no i think there are a lot of
ways h4 doesn't spoil the other yeah h4
okay h4
yeah and now
well yeah e instead of e4 of course i
could have played queen d2
uh
and and forced the trade on but then
knight c4 knight takes c4 rook c5 and
then and i mean yeah it's not
but it's not over it's not over because
i'll win the pawn with queen d4 but
but you know still room for uh
foreign but i couldn't i couldn't make
it happen yeah here it yeah
yeah this is a bit
yeah now it's
silly for me i think i don't know silly
but you still kept control of the game
enough yeah i hear g4 he joel joel joel
criticized me was shocked by this move
maybe he was criticizing me for playing
g4 i mean he knows how i love pawns but
but actually i didn't play g4 to just to
stop the eating of the h pawn i stopped
f5 this way that was my idea i didn't
want f5 to happen so i played g4 for
that race and i also didn't think that
the rook's so passive the queen alone
can do much so i don't know maybe i have
no idea i think it still maintains the
advantage all right still maintains the
advantage i don't think you lost it at
any point in that well that's that's
good news
and uh
and then
then of course at the end of the day
we traded queens max congratulations big
victory for you uh you're in the co-lead
right now going into the last
championship rounds three rounds to go
how do you feel about your chances
are you thinking about the title no no
i'm going to play each game you know i
have two blacks out of three so every
and
strong opponents everyone's strong here
so
uh i'll just enjoy myself like i've been
doing last six games go get your rest
get the energy up for the last leg of
this tournament and we'll see you
tomorrow okay thank you congratulations
uh max as we have more results uh
dorsa well max did win joel benjamin
three-way tie for first and the seniors
uh help me out here is there a
regulation if there is a three-way
player playoffs i don't know what they
are but
playoffs and sophie did win
um
yeah
yes
perfect six
can't she make it a car you wanna
you like that yesterday yeah i love it
alice lee came out of nowhere she was
just so dead busted i mean a complete
domination talia not only let it slip i
was looking at the ratings because i was
wondering about stuff is raining and uh
oh my god honestly it's raining and so
high uh
she's 23 48. exactly she's a top seed
so yeah she won good for her exactly
and then ellen wang at draw
this was an interesting game because i
was going back and forth on it that i we
didn't pay enough attention to it we
were looking at the games between the
tournament leaders actually that's what
had our attention yeah this is another
wonderful um back and forth game and how
many games do we have left i want to say
two good question
uh
gracie and zoe they're still hard at
work wait uh white has an exchange up
but
two pawns for the bishop i
i remember i looked at this game maybe
like
10 20 moves ago and it just felt like it
was
about to
you just felt like the king was in
danger you know there were a lot of fun
things happening but hey so how do you
feel about this current position
i love the fact that the bishop is
patrolling this diagonal and it has an
anchor square
keeps the a6 and the fact that we've got
some some passers over five yeah king h5
and uh
i
i don't oh what
should still be all right i guess
no bad
bad bad bad bad habits and end games you
have to learn to play actively sorry but
we do have our tournament leader yes
with
sophie sophie we are at a loss of words
here in the studio you're just playing
brilliant chess and the results keep on
coming how do you feel right now oh
i mean i'm doing better after like six
rounds than i've ever in this year than
ever i've ever done this tournament like
my entire life i think i played like
three times before
my highest score was like five out of
nine
obviously and now you're six out of six
now what are you doing in this
tournament differently
than your usual preparation rest what's
different that makes you have such a
high score and play such brilliant chess
um well i think the first thing i do
different is um i actually brought like
a physical board with me to help me prep
nice
so um i get like
i get the i get like the actual muscle
memory like i think it's it's working
very well this is my first time doing it
at an actual tournament by the way and
it definitely worked very well today
because you actually got a huge lead on
the clock in the opening phase you were
blitzing out your moves how did your
opening preparation go and when did it
finish
uh i finished after like
h4 and then my opponent played bishop
before which like i
i looked at it in like a different
position but not that position and then
i was kind of on my own
after bishop to f4 uh
without revealing too much what was the
main line here
um
you don't have to answer it do i think
queen to f2 okay
and then what was the continuation here
like h3 and then some craziness ensuing
on the board
excellent so she played bishop to f4
this was
the surprise
how did you assess this position right
now like
what were the nuances and the details
that you were looking at
um well
i thought it was like
probably equal at best for me honestly
yes and nightway 2 and you play this
move h3 after quite uh some thing now
after the move h3 what were the
candidate moves that you were looking at
um like here i was looking at i was
actually kind of more afraid of knight
b4 for white actually right before
and this was the move that we were
considering as well
perhaps the uh the engine actually
really liked the move knight to b4 at
least giving white a slight edge
but she played the move g3 and then
you responded with this vicious
sacrifice bishop takes e4
were you happy to see the move g3 and
allow you to do this yeah but then um
after f takes e4 i had a like panic
moment i guess because after knight g4 i
realized that queen e2 was possible um
which i didn't see in my calculations
but then even here like
i still have rick takes c5 queen takes
a6 and rook takes c1 and i don't know
when i have no idea what's happening
um so i was actually really hoping like
why i wouldn't play queen e2 um but
actually
like the more i looked at it the more i
thought this is maybe fine for me
and it was
the assessment actually after rook they
see one is zero zero zero
uh but still wise position very
difficult because of the king right
despite the fact that you have a lot of
let's say uh material advantage as white
still the king is very weak and uh in
fact it wasn't easy at all to play for
white right now now let's go back to the
game's position she played the move
queen to c2
and after this it just felt like you're
taking over
did you know that you're better right
now
um i suspect it was like just a position
i didn't know if i was better or not i
just thought like this is an acceptable
position and i can i could play it i
guess oh at this point it was just a
dominant situation and she played this
weird move a4
just uh not necessarily trapping her own
knight but not bringing the knight into
play as fast as she was supposed to
were you surprised by her decision i was
surprised by a four um i i i understood
it though because like
i'm my plan is to play brook c2 night
before rook c3
um
well that's one of my possible plans um
and then they there's like a few things
to calculate like with knight takes a6
and i think i was playing like queen a5
um
yeah and then
it might get stranded yeah on a6 yeah
then i stranded but like yeah i don't
know i i was expecting like bishop takes
h3 though yeah
and
she did not take that pawn on h3 and
well it was too late to pick it up after
that
the
it felt like after that the conversion
was quite smooth on
your part
sophie
a big victory for you six out of six
tomorrow you're playing for a caruana do
you know what that is oh yeah um
i forgot i forgot what karana score was
but it was like the sig field 2014 field
cup 2014 seeing through cups seven out
of seven so tomorrow you have a big
chance to do that congratulations and
take a look and admire your online score
just simply brilliant congratulations uh
sophie and uh we'll see you tomorrow
thank you
our congratulations as well very very
big game uh tomorrow for
playing jennifer you playing jennifer
you who lost today
as d'italia which gives uh sophia a
two-point lead
in the girls with three games remaining
can jennifer stop this runaway train or
do we see a car iwana
that's a very good way to ask
tune in tomorrow uh gracie sorry you are
asking what games we have left we have
gracie
and zoe and uh
i think we gotta go to dog pati mishra
because that is the one that could
potentially influence the standings
right now and they both are under uh
well
wonder one minute for balaji and one
minute and 40 seconds right now for
abimanu from
from what i saw in the last few moves
they've just been shuffling pieces like
that so i expect the draw to come up
perhaps there's no way to make any more
progress now the bishop on c4 has to
stay there defend the pawn on b5 and it
doesn't seem like you can get to that
knight on f3 the king and the knight are
doing a tremendous job
the rocket the the rocket has to stay on
c7 to protect the c4 the king can just
go back and forth the knight can
potentially go to h7 at some point
yeah this one just seems but be careful
if you go to h7 don't go king g7
because then that could allow me to go
uh f8 even then can i just take with the
king and then pick up the bishop on c4
you can yes yes and maybe even that is
is enough
yeah this kind of feels like it looks
scary but i i think both players kind of
know
i think we're just going to see a
repetition right now it doesn't seem
like balaji thinks that
he can do anything anymore at this point
actually i thought he was close to
winning earlier i'm a little bit
surprised
that the apon is somehow missing like
right about here
i was kind of thinking well don't you
just play you know rook to
f6 and
trundle your pawn up the board keeping
in mind that you you might have a b5 b6
so i was really surprised to see that
the a pawn was missing actually and i
didn't quite see how he maybe
accidentally got married yeah i got
knocked off the board there you go rook
takes a4 that's how he did it
and
mishra was just
i have to say that f pawn
looks uh so
threatening
hello but we have a guest as we'll keep
an eye on this game
we are indeed uh alice congratulations a
big victory for you and a difficult one
at that it felt like you were on the
defending end for the duration of the
game how did you feel and how do you
feel right now after this victory yeah
so i think um the opening like a kind of
neither of us knew exactly how to play
so i'm not sure how that went but
later she was kind of able to outplay me
and then she got
that queen side
the a and b pawns on the queen side
but it wasn't so easy for it to convert
so i was able to trade off the bishops
and then
she missed that i could do rook takes b3
and after that
it was kind of hard for me to play for
her to play so right now you are feeling
that you're a bit on defensive but still
having some chances for equality and we
were surprised that after this move f5
and you got your king to f1 she did not
go for your h5 pawn with the king
did you expect her to do that were you
surprised that she didn't go for it yeah
i was expecting her to take on h5 and
then like later play b4 where i don't
think i really have um counter play and
then she's dressed up by
a pawn
but she decided to bring her keen in i
guess
to
help with the queen side but
then she allowed me to do bishop takes
p3 and here
she's forced to do ajax b3 because i
think if rectax b3 is in rook a2
um so after it takes b3 i kind of have a
blockade
um
that's what we thought as well yeah yeah
i thought that i was still had to defend
here yeah did you see this moment this
idea of rook takes b3 from afar were you
hoping that she's going to touch that
rook when you gave the check
yeah so when i played rocket five check
um my hope was that she'd do it b5 um
the
work on b4 if you had done that work
then i think i would have gone rook a6
um
and then
yeah then she can't move her keen and
the rooks are still kind of um awkwardly
placed so now it just feels like you're
getting close to potentially a perpetual
yeah
a repetition and
she played the movie rook to be how did
you assess your chances of winning at
this point did you feel like
you have good chances to uh to take the
full point home
yeah um so after i was able to play e4
i wasn't sure whether it was winning or
not but i thought that i had really good
chances because i
clock was much lower and because i can
press and play this position without any
risks of losing
absolutely and there was a well a smooth
conversion after that uh
also accelerated by the fact that she
was so low on time at this point alice
congratulations a big victory for you
and we're looking forward to see you in
the next few games thank you
wow our congratulations alice it's
wonderful to see
unfortunately we've got two games left
but because of what's going on here at
the st louis chess club with all of the
remodeling and things their kicking is
out
they're simply kicking us off
but let's go to the standings with two
games remaining dorsa do the honors
who's in first oh well who was nothing
there you go we have three legends tied
for the first place
uh chris oh my god christensen thank you
and maxim delugey yes and in the ladies
section oh we don't have that yet
but we know
the soul reader two points in the lead
actually essentially
and the juniors again have one game we
expect that game to be a draw it's
really hard to imagine any other way to
be honest exactly exactly
blunders are i'm going to call that one
it's going to be a draw yeah but we
really have to give a shout out to
christopher you because he's doing he's
doing so phenomenally well come on five
and a half out of six only
overshadowed by sophie's perfect score
but look at that score i'm gonna have
ahead of one and a half points ahead of
andrew
and mishra final thoughts christian as
we get ready to get kicked out for all
the drillers and would be um
keepers guys the leaders uh in the
junior sections are creating some
separation and that fantastic six out of
six by sophie maury suzuki is just
simply
incredible i i'm lost for words about
that performance and i have to say
christopher you is not very far behind
five and a half out of six against such
level of competition that uh he is
meeting right now is just incredible and
the situation and uh the leadership is
hitting up in the seniors section three
leaders as we go on to the last three
rounds guys we're going to have
fantastic chess and battles in all three
sections i'm looking forward to it
absolutely dorset good to call the
action with you thank you thank you
everybody for sharing your day we will
see you all tomorrow good night from st
louis
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you